Hello everybody!
One second, I'm looking at...
Okay, good.
I have been...
I have been doing many things today, so...
We're including some recordings, so I was making sure my
settings were all...
Good.
I think I would have done that before.
stream.
Yay!
Hello!
Welcome back to Grim Fandango.
Hope you're not too tired.
I am a little tired.
But that's okay.
I did get a lot done, though.
I did get a lot done that I needed to get done.
So, Andregos!
Thank you so much for the fun, Getson.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Linus!
Thank you so much for the Tango!
Thank you!
you hello we don't i was like you i've missed you dearly
minto it's been 24 hours it's been less than that because i
i stopped stream later than this time so it's been a little
bit more than 24 or less than 24 hours thank you so much for
the vibe gifted it felt long now okay but this is also me
with my favorite streamers too I'll be like man why can't
they just be live 24 7 so that I can always have them on
like man why can't my streamers stream longer and more and
why can't they do it for just me
that's what VODs are for I'll go find a VOD that's like a
couple years old and I'll be like, okay, surely I don't
remember what happened in this.
So, hello little Tyre and Minto, I'm proud of you for being
so productive.
Mixer!
Thank you!
Yeah!
I have been productive.
As a general heads up, Rubikava is much bigger than the
first area.
Be prepared for a lot of searching.
Some puzzle pieces might be far apart.
Love you.
Oh, thank you, Sparn.
Thank you.
Thanks for the heads up warning.
Wait, do you mean that in that this chapter might take a
little longer too?
We might split it into two parts then.
We might split it into two parts then if that's the case.
Waitress, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Waitress, I gotta have more Mito.
Saku!
It definitely will.
Okay, okay.
This will definitely take longer.
No worries then.
Finally a streamer who says what everyone's thinking.
Long time no Mito.
I recently had a final interview and would like to request
some positive vibes and energy.
Near one year since laid off in Kuzoza!
Good luck!
Positive energy!
Beam!
Some places saying three to four hours for chapter two.
Go- wait!
Just three to four hours, that's what I did yesterday.
Well then, should we just hop into it then so that I
don't...
Hopefully I don't yapp too much.
Well, I say that.
But I know there will be people be like No, yop more, VTuber
Yop more, VTuber Yeah, you have to account for like streamer
time You have to account for streamer time I think for some
of these games Where it's like Add an extra two hours or
something Yop more, VTuber I love your yopping Thank you
What have I done?
Oh my gosh, with my move.
Well, today was just a lot of catch-up work as well.
Me catching up on stuff that I've missed.
Three to four hours is six to seven Minto hours.
Yeah, pretty much.
I caught half of Matto's new podcast.
The word you were looking for is ephemera.
Is that?
Oh my gosh, Jordan!
Wait, I'm looking at it real quick.
Ephemera.
Yes, I am on.
Yes, yes, that's exactly it.
I was on Matara's new podcast.
They can describe a lot of context for specific periods of
time.
Yeah.
Hi, Minto, yesterday was my birthday.
Empirical, Empirical Cube!
Happy birthday!
Why aren't you a skeleton?
Why would I be a skeleton, huh?
Why would I want to be all bony and weird?
I'm goopy and cool instead.
Quite literally.
Thanks for playing one of my favorite games growing up.
Thank you for coming by and watching.
Appreciate it.
This VTuber is boneless.
You could do a skelly dance, though.
I kind of am jealous of skeletons because sometimes I wish
that I could take my bones off and then play them like a you
know like a maramba marimba it's nice and to chill after a
long day of work with a cute silly point click game thank
you for all that you do me don't thank you for snow
xylophone what's wait what's the difference between a
marimba and a xylophone right now Mitophone
Both work That's what I thought Marimba is fancy Oh Baby
Gord, thank you so much for the vibe Good thing I'm able to
catch another stream What's so funny?
Why are you laughing?
But uh Yeah, I don't know tried to uh today was like some uh
what's the word admin stuff so it wasn't very fun things
that i've done today you know like oh i gotta update these
files and update these these addresses and update these
things and that things so marimba is bigger it can go up
five octaves and goes way lower Oh.
Admin for new cafe or admin for Denzatsu?
Well, I did do some Denzatsu stuff as well.
Yeah.
We recorded the podcast after stream yesterday.
Which is a good time.
Good thing I ended when I did because, like, I ended.
And then I got a notification on my phone.
And it was, like, 30 minutes until podcasting recording.
And I was like, we're podcast recording.
And I was like, I totally...
Do that!
For those who don't know, Denzatsu, the idol group I'm in,
we have a Patreon!
And we do a monthly podcast and some monthly goodies and
things that we send out as well.
If you are so inclined to check it out.
So on top of it, Queen.
Always?
Hopefully you had the time to do what you had to do
afterwards too.
That was done this morning.
Yeah, we have a Discord server too.
I pop in there from time to time, so...
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll just come in there.
I'll just be like, hey!
Hey guys!
Wonder how the TikTok channel's doing.
I have so many more dinosaur things I could share.
That's where the hell's at.
is yeah jump scare sometimes if people are in the voice chat
i'll be like i'll be like i'm gonna go in i'm gonna go in
i've done that only once though i should do it again next
time i see somebody in the voice chat i'll be like hi hi so
yeah that's actual jump scares and things
She could be anywhere.
I'm right here.
Oh, camp the VC.
That'd be fun.
Yeah, just always be in there.
Just never leave when you're asleep.
When you go on party.
Taking a shower.
Doing the dishes.
Taking a walk.
Doing your grocery shopping.
yeah there you go i'll just you know one day i'll pop in
i'll be like boom and i'll leave
but shall we get back into grim fandango it is one year
later and we are now the great gatsby or something and it's
awesome does the music makes you want Makes you funky.
Yeah, me too, this one.
All right.
But someone said that they are wanting to meet us.
So let's go see.
Let's go see what's going on.
La la la.
Oh.
It's so quiet now.
Hello?
Oh, okay.
Who are you?
We got a Pikmin run in this place.
Oh, no.
Oh, wow.
We're so honest.
Hello, Manny.
Hola.
What?
This suit?
He's on the plate.
Quiet night?
Quiet night, huh, Cardinal?
Day of the dead ain't good for business, chief.
But last night, remember last night, Manny?
Oh, wait.
I was going to say, We didn't actually get to go to that
festival, the parade.
That's so sad.
He's a gentleman, dapper glottis.
Oh, he's so talented.
He can play Frozen in Time as well.
What's that you're playing?
Oh, this is just a little, you know, love song for a special
lady.
Special lady.
Is it Eva?
Sing a little bit of that song.
Is he gonna sing?
Well, I only have this part.
I like it.
Man,
he sounded so sincere.
I like it.
I do wonder if...
I wonder if, like, who recorded their lines first for the
voice actors?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
burn wagon and then so I would say like Manny Manny's person
hadn't heard GLaDOS's lines yet and was just like yeah I
like it you think she'll come in tonight you think she'll
come in tonight oh my special lady no Mitchie you know what
Manny I think she will I got a feeling tonight's the night
tonight's the night she's been traversing the forest for a
whole year?
You know, when we leave, I'm actually gonna miss this place.
Ah, Manny, why can't we just stay here?
We got our fancy club, we got three squares a day.
Max lets me take the bone wagon out on his kitty sack once a
week.
Plus, we look good in these clothes.
Gladys, I can't live in this world forever.
It's not where I belong.
I've gotta find Mecha and Helper, because if it weren't for
me, she'd have been on that train a year ago.
Okay, Manny.
done well i'll let you get back to practicing i don't need
to practice man i'm good you're so good glottis plus we look
good in these clothes he looks i guess glottis is good at
anything that uses keys dang where do we go this way
what's up
ah marillo de oro a very Fine liqueur filled with solid gold
flakes.
Nothing but the best for my customers.
My rich customers.
This place is fancy.
Fancy living.
What's this?
Yes, I better take this with me.
Yes, for safe keeping.
For safe keeping.
All right.
I mean, it's my place.
Why can't I take it?
What the heck?
Who are you?
Who are these people?
Chao Chilla Charlie.
I sit down Charlie of course not many I mean it is your club
right sands under tail smoking no would it everybody be
sands no this is charge charge chinchilla Charlie why aren't
yeah why aren't you over why aren't you over at the roulette
tables the roulette is for lonely widows and Frenchmen why
don't you get some slot machines manny everybody old women
little children they all love slot machines ghost maids and
I have a system an infallible system for beating them
Coachella Charlie I'll think about it well I think slot
machines attract an undesirable element all my friends are
lonely widows and Frenchmen I'll think about it yeah i can
tell when you're just yeah what about pachinko now what are
you doing in my club charlie what are you doing in my club
chinchilla charlie did not tell you not to come back until
you can pay your bar cap oh or they kicked me out of that
cat track for printing fake bedding stuffs so now i have to
come here manny which i love which i love but you're not
allowed here you owe me money
um all my friends are long all my friends are lonely widows
and frenchmen except me manny i'm here to keep you sane it
sounds like we just brought that up on prompted what's tell
me your system what's the system tell me your system charlie
i can't tell you my secrets uh just this you have to become
one with what about glottis you have to get inside the
machine and and make it one to pay On second thoughts, stay
away from my roulette tables.
That's a nice suit.
Where'd you steal it?
Manny, if you learn to play the odds like Chow Chila
Charlie, then maybe you too can have a suit this fine
someday.
Mine looks better, I think.
How did you print fake bedding?
How did you print fake bedding stubs?
With this.
Oh, wow.
What is that?
The last time I was incarcerated I shared a cell with the
most dishonest con man I ever met he was strictly small-time
and I managed to steal this from him quite easily you never
know this may come in handy okay hey give that back to me
Manny maybe once you sell your bar tab hey Charlie yeah
Charlie Manny wink what else can you counterfeit what else
can you counterfeit nothing anything something's happened to
Manny model i don't know what's going on uh what about oh
can you make passports so can you make passports manny you
still think like a living man in so many ways no soul needs
a passport we are all citizens of the same nation and our
king rides a pale horse so no passports no no that little
hologram is so tricky you know i get it what about driver's
license how about driver's licenses sure just a little stiff
yeah give me a recent picture 50 bucks in about two weeks
okay i think of something i need i'll come back that's a
long time i'm not a wishing well manny well i gotta go i've
got a club to run so i'm not gonna call oh yes the people
that play slots unfavorable with your glamorous life my
glamorous afterlife thank you very much It's really long,
no?
Try to get a passport from Chinchilla Charlie.
There's so many people here.
Who are you?
An honest roulette croupier is hard to find.
And guys like this, even harder.
Who are you?
Ah, my bread and butter.
Thrills seeking rich folk with a poor grasp of statistics
and probability.
Who are you?
Ah, my bread and butter.
Oh.
Thrills seeking rich folk with a poor grasp of statistics
and probability.
Why can't I talk to her?
Who are you?
Police, Jesus.
Rubacava's finest.
Rubacava's only for that matter.
Le Cinque, Rouge, and Paribank.
Five, red.
Who's speaking French over there?
Wait, can I get out of here?
Madam and monsieur, fed for sure, if you please.
Ladies and gentlemen, please, please, your bet!
Some people say you should always walk away from the table
when you're on a winning streak.
I'm feeling extra lucky tonight.
What about you?
Madame, monsieur, learn about you.
Everything okay down here?
I'm going to need some more chips.
If monsieur, lucky does not call it a night song.
Mmm.
What if we give him the liqueur?
Yes, sir.
I think you could use this little drink to...
I don't really want to do that.
Oh, okay.
What about you?
Madame, monsieur, fed for sure.
I don't really want to do that.
Ladies and gentlemen, please.
I was going to make him drunk so that he would lose.
Am I wrong in thinking a casino needs bunny girls?
I think everywhere needs bunny girls.
The grocery store.
The post office.
Ladies and gentlemen, betting is closed.
No more bets, please.
I can't literally think of one place that would go without
bunny girls.
That's my suggestion.
Okay, we have no items again.
but we're stuck in here so let's leave again
was that the guy who wanted to see me or the person that
called me down or whatever
oh oh yeah there's here too
looks like lupus been in the sugar again maybe except for a
morgue hear me out you dress bunny girls evening Lupe hi
Manny oh I have to tell you about my new organizational
system for the coats no you don't okay back to work but my
system I'll be back okay who's here oh
Manny Help me.
I've been lost for so long.
Why didn't you look for me?
I did.
You ran off.
Why?
Because you said I was no good.
I've been all alone in the world for a whole year.
And it's all because of you!
Is this a dream?
Oh.
What?
Dang, we're good at tracking this guy.
Never mind.
No, don't let him.
Don't let him out of your sight.
There you go.
Oh my god!
This really is the great Gatsby.
No, Davina!
No!
Nice, good job.
Oh.
What the?
Why'd she do that?
Oh.
This gonna be an annual thing with you, Manny?
day of the dead you toss your bones into the drink and i
fish him out i don't plan to be around that long belasco as
soon as i find out with that ocean liner's going i'm after
it ha ha that ship's going to puerto zapato that's the other
side of the world there's no ships going out that way but
the old limbo here but but not if the limbo's my only hope
then i'm already on board well good luck son that's all i
got to say
Ooh, why is the moon like that?
What's going on in that bottle?
A tugboat?
This happens to be a perfect scale replica of the SS
Lumbago.
Just having a little trouble.
Yeah, the moon's got a face, squeepy.
To fill in the neck here.
That's funny.
Because the Lumbago is usually more of a problem in the
lower back than the neck.
Hmm.
Yeah, hmm.
Nothing.
I have to go.
I better go finish packing.
Aye, you do that, son.
Oh what is going on there I don't get the joke is that an
old person it's shown palest bone as I stood there alone and
I thought to myself how the moon that night cast its light
on my heart's true delight and the reef where her body was
true lumbar joke lumbago is a lower back injury no way
really
don't have that kind of equipment don't have that kind of
equipment I'd get the moon for you something something
alright so now we have to go back to our club and pack
question mark what's going on over here the riffraff who are
you guys what are you oh my game seems a little buggy today
does it not Mmm, these bees don't seem too busy.
I'm gonna just save.
Well, well, uh...
Cold one, huh, Terry?
Yeah, it's always cold when you're unemployed, Manny.
Dang.
Why aren't you up there working?
Why aren't you guys up there working?
You don't know the deal down here on the docks, do you,
Manny?
If you want to get the jobs, you have to pay the millions
extra dues.
I meant it seriously.
But also...
Wait.
If the union is crooked, why don't you represent your...
I can't tolerate all this injustice.
I'm leaving.
Skull moon is beautiful tonight, isn't it, Minto?
I saw her body strewn in the...
I can't tolerate all this injustice.
I'm leaving.
Things just aren't the way they should be down here, Manny.
I didn't mean to actually put that.
They do all the work.
affect the uh the uh ah it's like the way the things are
produced should be controlled by i mean we should just the
social work like the i'm just a dumb hungry out of work b
the injustice what's the buzz boys you're getting close
terry it's like it's like we want to control the means
You're so close, Terry.
You're so close.
You have to register a complaint.
If the union is crooked, why don't you register a complaint?
That's such a...
That is a funny little thing to say.
He thinks we should register a complaint.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
It's funny because, man, I guess, has Manny forgotten that
he's like, uh...
He's part of the resistance.
Oh.
Where'd that guy go?
Oh, they're just zooming around.
Who's unemployed?
Aren't you guys in the union?
The union?
We've got a lot of resistance!
Look after us little guys!
They're run by the coppers!
And you of all people should know, Manny, that the cops are
in bed with the gambling joints.
What?
I'm a gambling joint.
Uh-oh.
I run an honest joint.
Hey, I run an honest joint.
We ain't in bed with nobody.
What about the...
I'm eating pasta.
We pay every week.
On the nose, through the nose, like an honest place should.
See what I mean?
This town is just a big conga line of hustlers.
All laughing and dancing and scratching each other's backs.
I think you're just a bunch of complainers.
You don't know what it's like, man.
Every day we come down here, we try and make an honest
living.
We find out that you gotta be a- It's just pasta and butter.
It's just pasta and butter.
He knocks the pollen out of you, man.
He makes you weak.
If the cops own the union and gambling's in bed with the
cops...
Yeah, yeah, and then who really runs the gambling, right?
Well, no offense, but, uh, Maximino is really the big boy in
town, obviously.
But word is, he gets his orders from some hardcore gangster.
as an elmero yeah that fancy cat track is really just a big
laundromat if you get my drift um yeah too much and it's too
much injustice i can't tolerate all this injustice i'm
leaving easy for you to say top cider oh gosh it's just too
much these bees don't seem too busy we can talk to everybody
boys i mean you know what's wrong manny we workers have to
do everything oh only terry talks nobody else wants to talk
to me yeah i can't give it tolerate all this injustice i'm
leaving easy for you to say topside easy for you to say
topside we came from this way right so let's see what's over
here the blue casket okay this is the other side i believe
topside yeah we're here now so we came from there what's
here
Oh.
What's here?
I should talk to the captain more.
I'll explain your objectives.
Wait, I'm exploring right now, though.
Oh.
What's down here?
Whoa.
Can we take this and set it?
There it is.
Max's giant cat racetrack.
Now's a regular guy with three roulette tables supposed to
compete with that.
But your place seems nice.
seems doing well, no?
What we got down in there?
Everything sounds like I'm a loser.
I get somewhere.
Oh, is that stew?
What you're cooking?
Oh, we're going in?
Wait, what?
Bone soup?
Wait.
What the hell?
Where do we file our complaints?
What just happened?
I went into the stew.
I'm yawinging that, whatever it is.
Whoop, I need that.
Oh?
Need to hold still, or I need to strap you down.
What's this?
Oh, that reminds me.
I forgot about my date with Inez.
We have a date?
Not picking that up.
Oh, okay.
Hello, operator?
Yeah, it's me, baby.
How'd you know?
Hey.
Don't say that, sweetheart.
You know I meant to stop by and...
I'm more happy about leaving town every minute.
We had a date.
We're so casual about it.
Manny, Manny, you've changed.
Who's this?
Looks like it hurts.
Who are you?
It's Toto Santos, Rubacaba's friendly Scrimshaw artist.
Oh.
Thanks for telling that to the wall.
Hola, Toto.
Como estas?
Not now, Manny.
I'm in the middle of something with Naranya here.
Naranya.
Okay.
See ya.
Weep, weep, weep, weep, weep.
Naranya is orange.
His name is orange?
I want an orange.
What's this way?
Oh, just kidding.
Just kidding.
Wait, it's gonna play the sound again.
Oh.
It doesn't.
Whop, whop, whop.
Okay.
Welcome back to a membership.
Thank you very much.
Can I go in there?
No?
No comment?
Nothing?
What's this?
That's the folding bridge that connects this pier to the
base of the cat track.
Oh.
Well, let's use it.
Let's do it.
Let's pull it.
Let's go.
What the heck?
Why is it like that?
Look at all the seifuku!
What's this way?
Big cat.
This place is humongous.
Holy cow.
Somebody really liked this cat.
Look at his face.
Kitty?
I don't need one of those.
I need a cat.
They don't have much use when they're alive and stuff.
They don't have much more.
He looks pissed.
I mean, I would be too.
What's in here?
I heard a cat.
That smell is better than the muerte.
Oh my god, it's just a giant litter box.
Wait, yoink?
There's something there, too.
I dare you.
This cat litter really needs changing.
It's tempting as it is.
I just can't bring myself to jump in the giant unclean kitty
litter.
Valid.
Joker, I made him lose it.
It says revolutionary design leaves canages safe and smooth
for kitty.
Oh!
Yoink.
Thank you.
food wet foods for winners mmm I could open it with my teeth
but I'm not that hungry see oh what's going on something big
something big's happening the game the game the World Cup
I'm not sure what I hate crowds or cats but I'm definitely
not going near either one today how could you hate a cat
this place is bopping Wow, wow, it's...
What?
Hey who?
Hey...
Oh, we can watch him here.
It's like a great night for cat races.
Closing ground.
This is Umamusame, you guys.
This is actually Umamusame.
Nobody there.
That means I can go in.
Oh, sorry, monsieur, but this is the elevator to the high
rollers lounge.
That's where I'm going.
It is members only.
You must be new.
And you must have a VIP pass to come upstairs.
Adieu.
Snowballs triumph.
Chase getting up, licking herself off.
Sounds like something we gotta get counterfeit.
Sounds like something we got to ask a guy to print for us.
Oh, wait.
Well, I thought you could use the company with everybody
gone for the day of the dead.
In that case, Manny, why don't you stick around until 6?
That's when I get off.
I had a date.
I blew them off, actually.
What's that?
Why is there a manhole right there?
When did you put in a floor safe?
That's our new contained detonation chamber in case someone
tries to come through here with a bomb.
does Rubicaba have a terrorism problem?
This town's changing, Manny.
It's getting tougher every day.
We don't know if anyone's gonna come in here with a bomb,
but we can't take any chances.
I just love this that says, lol.
What's this?
That voice.
A lot of passengers.
Everybody's back home, but you and me.
Oh, everybody getting getting into it with a skelly lady can
i try out your metal detector carla busy night hardly
everybody's gone home for the holiday already this place is
dead and i'm bored manny bored no why don't you come by the
club anymore why don't you come by the club anymore well to
tell you the truth manny it's your little coat check girl
all that bubbly energy i just want to strangle i've tried
that it doesn't stop
Oh, you mean you're quiet?
What's the shuttle waiting for?
Oh, they're just cleaning it, but they're very thorough.
So I am finishing my pasta.
I'm finishing my pasta because I didn't finish it before
stream.
So I didn't have time.
Actually, I forgot about it on the stove.
I went back and I was like, Ah!
Ah!
It's on the stove!
You guys ever just in the mood for like plain ash posh?
Like I like just an angel hair with some olive oil and
butter and that's it.
That's it.
Yummy!
No, there's no sauce.
The sauce is the... is the noodle.
Oil and garlic.
I don't have any garlic, though.
I need to go grocery shopping.
That sounds like girl dinner.
Girl dinner.
Well, it is my dinner and I am a girl, so...
You know.
I'm a simple ghost.
I don't need much.
Can I try out your metal detector?
What's your sudden interest in metal detectors, Manny?
I actually don't know why we want it.
I need to borrow it for a secret project.
I just want to borrow it for a secret project.
Well, I'll show it to you when I'm on break.
How's that?
I think it's time for your break, Carla.
I think it's time for your break.
We could slip in the back for a little drink.
You can tell me all about your job, the danger, the metal
detectors.
That backroom's all business, Manny.
So am I.
When's your break?
Oh, that's too late.
I'm shipping out tonight.
Yeah, right.
I've fallen for that line too many times.
Carly, you gotta believe me, baby girl.
What kind of business goes on back there, Carly?
Strip searches.
Hmm.
And you don't qualify.
I thought she liked me.
Why don't I qualify for a strip search?
Manny, I agree it would help pass the time.
but we have procedures and rules here.
And you never know when they're watching.
I can only strip search people when a regular search turns
up nothing.
Hey, it's worth a try.
Ooh, I love this part.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
Sorry, I have a bomb, Officer.
Sir, if you will, please place all of your belongings on the
security desk.
What am I putting on there?
Oh.
Is this the strip search?
Oh, you're clean.
Oh Rats manny.
I almost got to strip search you.
Okay, I'll come back and let you take off my clothes She's
so insistent She's so insistent Don't take off my clothes
officer lady
Uh, what was the this was the way out all right let's uh go
talk to what's his name again the the uh captain wait what's
this cho cho matey cho my day no no no oh well damn it i
knew that was gonna happen
this gate only leads up to the lambada dock lambada is the
the thing the what's called it's not a blimp hey
buddy the ship wait
the lambada was the one that wait was the lambada the one
that the ship that left i thought it was the zeppelin yeah
wait i'm ready all right so i'm ready to sail on what on the
limbo man let's go man hey manny manny the limbo's not a
passenger and every hand on board works i'll work i'll work
what are your skills sales and restaurant management oh hey
there is one opening on the limbo's crew yeah yeah it's in
the engine room and your buddy glottis would be perfect for
it but you'd have to get his own tools i go with glottis
we're we're a team we're a dual we're a dual person i'm
literally we're like join twins.
I thought the ship that left was the Lumbago.
There's too many!
There's too many things to start with L's and are sound
similar.
Yeah, we're a package deal.
What kind of tools does Gladys need?
Authentic CB equipment only.
What, what, what, where do I get authentic CB?
Where do I get authentic CB equipment?
Why don't you ask a CB?
Afraid of getting stung.
Oh, like a B, like an actual one.
So if I get the tools we can board?
Okay, if I get Gladys some tools, can we board?
Uh, he can, yes.
No offense, Manny, but there's just no place for you aboard
the limbo.
She's fully manned already.
In fact, her whole crew's on board, ready to sail at dawn.
Except for that one guy.
Who's the one guy?
Who's the one guy who hasn't boarded yet?
Well, Seaman Naranja's a little...
Naranja!
But he'll be here before they sail.
What, what did he, what was his job?
What job did Naranja have?
Naranja, Naranja.
Rest to our management.
Yeah, it's similar to what you're doing now.
Except the fish is fresher on the limbo.
Orange, yeah.
Where do you, I know where he is.
What if Naranja doesn't show up?
I can feel the smart, right?
Mandy, you're not even in the Maritime Union.
I know that and you know that, but we're two guys who can
keep secrets, right?
I'll even put on a uniform.
But the captain will ask for your card.
And if you don't have one, they'll serve you to the sharks
like chum.
Okay, another thing I need to counterfeit.
That's a tough union, boy, and I don't mess with them.
Manny is pronouncing it right.
Yeah, I know.
I know.
But I like the captain.
So let me get this straight.
If I get Gladys some tools, then I can get him a job on the
limbo.
And if Semen Narangha doesn't show up for work, but he
will...
And I get a maritime union card, which you'll never get.
Then I can sail on the limbo in the morning.
Sheesh.
I guess so.
More adventures in the underworld with Manny and Minto.
Oh, fun little Easter egg.
Try typing blam.
You type blam?
What do you think, Narangha?
I'll try it.
with a drip.
I better go finish packing.
He's an absolute, he's so diligent.
He's definitely doing that.
It hurts so bad.
I even lost my clothes and changed them and then re-wore
them.
Wait, that was craziness.
Alright.
Let's go talk to the bees.
The bees.
Terry.
Terry, Terry, Terry, Terry.
I've never seen that.
These bees don't seem too busy.
Hello.
What's the buzz, boys?
It's like the big union guys and us and they, they don't,
uh, I mean, we don't ever get, uh, you know, we're just,
we're sick of it.
I know you're sick of it.
I know.
Since you're not using your tools, since you're not using
your tools, think I could borrow them?
Families and how are you ever gonna work?
Yeah, I told you things were messed up down here man.
Yeah, I told you.
Oh my god Can I borrow one of your union cards?
Hey, can I borrow one of your union cards?
What are you kidding?
You know how much I had to pay chow chow chowly to get mine?
You should do something about it.
You guys are being exploited.
Yeah, what can we do?
What is the handful of unorganized drones?
We don't know nothing about nothing except just how to take
it on a chin what does that mean like a butt like a like a
punch you guys know a semen naranja nah sebees and sailors
don't about a semen naranja maybe so but some traditions are
sacred there many like a punch okay okay why don't you just
pay the union off then we got our pride yeah that's what I
was thinking you know not to mention we just don't have any
cash to despair now that we're not working it's like a bad
cycle the solution makes the problem worse like a catch-22
yeah wow i wish i knew ways like that you bees gotta be
strong easy for you to say cop cider be strong
he doesn't know words guys it's so sad did i go in here i
don't think i did actually now i think Oh.
Oh.
Ouch.
What's up here?
Oh my god.
It gets even larger.
What the hell?
Oh my god.
What's in here?
Why is it so...
serious and spooky late night at the morgue isn't him embryo
oh no they're sprouted you know i can't sleep with john doze
on the slab manny if i don't id these rose gardens tonight i
won't be ready for the two that come in tomorrow and before
you know it i'm up to my ass in his areas Oh, his voice is
cool.
Any leads?
I know it's a poor coroner who blames his tools, Manny.
But how am I supposed to turn up anything with the equipment
they give me?
Hey, I had a government job for years, man.
I know how you feel.
The voice acting in this game is like too crazy.
Digging through flower beds is Mambrio's job, not mine.
I don't think picking flowers is really appropriate right
now.
sad story these two sprouted and no one came down to claim
them death makes sad stories of us what causes a guy to
sprout you know besides like the one dude shooting them what
exactly are you looking for just being shot digging for a
treasure that part of me does not wish to find for when I
uncover that sad So it's just the shooting?
Okay.
That tells me who this poor soul is.
My reward is not riches, but the chance to make a phone call
and break somebody's heart.
Of course, with this equipment, the search could go on for
some time.
What kind of equipment are you talking about?
How's business?
Booming, unfortunately.
I was gonna say!
More crime every day.
And more and more sproutings like these something's
happening back in Elmoro, I think and its dark hand is
finally reaching us here in Rubikava Oh, Elmoro's where we
came from because it was like the marrow from the trees,
right?
Why do you stay in town?
Can I help?
Sure.
Grab hold of this leaf right here.
Yes.
I got you Manny I can't do it.
I know I I was just testing.
Is it that strange?
I mean, you're already skellies and they're skellies.
Hmm.
How do you do this job?
Without becoming jaded, you mean?
My secret to happiness, Manuel.
Is that I have the heart of the 12-year-old boy.
Blooming!
I keep it over here in a jar.
Would you like to see it?
No.
Sorry.
Dang!
I kind of want to say it.
Do you ever worry that your job is getting to you, member
you?
Well, forensic botany is a trying job, Manny.
But have you ever spent much time here as a florist?
Classic in a jar joke.
In life, they became florists because they love flowers.
But here, a flower is a symbol of pain.
Darko thinking so much!
Of death within death.
Their conflicted feelings build and build.
and eventually they become quite mad.
Thanks for the tip.
I guess I'll send balloon bouquets from now on.
Embryo, why do you stay in town?
Why don't you head off toward the ninth underworld?
Manny, you can only search for something for so many years
before you stop believing in it altogether.
You don't believe in the ninth underworld?
Why do you think we're all here in Rubicaba?
Because you're waiting to earn off your time or you can't
afford passage.
up all of us when you've been here long enough you will too
well don't let me bother you always nice to have visitors no
we've given up no we have to believe it's real what is this
place what is the jail reward offered for cargo stolen from
shipyard receiving area including a large suitcase bearing
the initials hl hl and the coffee hmm i think i can remember
that a suitcase that says hl okay what's this what a
horrible jail cell then again he sure taught glottis a
lesson that time wait glottis was in jail not picking that
up what did glottis do what could glottis even do Half-life.
What an intriguing statue.
What's it mean?
I know that statue is supposed to mean something about
justice, but I don't know.
That's what it's...
Thanks, Vanny.
Glottis did glottis things, truly.
Looks like he's busting a move.
Hey, the new blimp is already in full operation.
Let's just hope they fill it with something non-flammable
this time.
Or even more flammable.
Oh, these are freaky looking, too.
The single post lamp in the middle of the street.
Oh, what?
Oh, it's a big circle.
Oh, this leads back to our not-girlfriend.
Okay, okay, okay.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
But there was something else over here that I hadn't still
checked out.
Inflammable means flammable.
It's not what a country, it's what a language, no?
Up here.
So the first thing I'm gonna do after we check out all this
though is go to our friend Chinchilla Man and get our...
Oh, go to a cafe, our rival.
We're gonna go to a chinchilla and see if he can get
something made for us.
Don't forget to save.
Thank you.
This... something about this reminds me of like...
Wait a second, isn't this our place?
Oh, this is our place!
Oh, good!
Oh, I didn't even notice!
Okay, cool.
for us?
I guess the guy that will give us the counterfeit stuff?
Oops, that's not where I wanted to go.
We want to go downstairs this way.
Hee hee hee.
Nope.
The...
This way.
Glottis, I hope you're good.
Wait, Glottis?
Do you want to go on a boat?
You gotta ask about who was here for you.
Oh, I never asked I just had a run-in with Domino and Meche.
We're leaving town.
What?
How?
Domino's got Meche.
We're going after them tonight.
What should I do?
Just sit here until I get a boat.
Sit here.
Check.
Okay.
Sounds good.
I know it.
Cute.
Hello, little lady.
Evening, Lupe.
Lupe.
Hi, Mary.
So...
uh how's the flow tonight how's the flow tonight we're dead
tonight manny everybody's back home for the day of the dead
i guess except for the casino the casino's hopping why is it
that all the people who don't go home are the same people
who just love to gamble well i guess when you've got nothing
to go home to you've got nothing to lose hey we should put
that over the door oh think she'll come in tonight think
she'll come in tonight manny you ask me that every night
what am i supposed to say you're supposed to say yes yeah
you're supposed to say yes i think tonight's the night yes i
think tonight's the night that you finally go nuts from
waiting for the grand entrance of miss mercedes colomar um
yeah let's let's try that again come on do you think she'll
come in tonight yes i think tonight's definitely the night
thank you it's my fault she's out in the woods but also i
guess we should have talked to her before we should talk to
her before going in seeing her huh uh everything okay back
in the land of fur and fedora everything's in order oopsie i
can't wait for people to come in and try the new system it's
so cool want to hear about it okay okay yeah i already ran
into her on accident oopsie okay i found all these plastic
tiles in the back left over from the automat and guess what
what they all have numbers on them so what i'm doing is i
give one to everyone oh it's a code check oh maddie you're
not even listening to me i go to all this work organizing
your coats and you don't even care loopy forget it don't
pretend to care no i want to hear help no i'll tell someone
else about it someone who cares please tell me Please, tell
me all about your new Ko-Chick system, really.
Don't patronize me, Cal.
Okay, back to work.
Okay.
She didn't tell me, though.
Oh, I went the wrong way again.
She also didn't tell me.
Oops.
Grim Bandango, vamos senorita mito.
Hello.
All right, buddy.
My little chinchilla.
My little, my little Chico Chinchella.
I love how this underworld is so sad and depressing, but all
the characters are very funny and silly.
The contrast is very appealing to me.
It is, it is silly, right?
Yeah.
Can you make reasonable union cards?
Manny.
Are you going to start moonlighting?
Or are you just looking to hang out with the sailors?
Can you do it or not?
Hmm.
I have a deal for you.
Yeah.
If you can retrieve my money from Max and Mino, I can make
you president of that crooked union.
I don't need to be president.
And why does Max have your money?
I put a whole suitcase of it up for collateral on a rather
large wager last month.
With the HL?
The race is fixed, Manny.
They stole my money like common thieves.
Oh, owns the track.
That's right.
Take this VIP pass.
The users will get into the high rollers lounge.
They won't let me in there anymore.
There should be a safe.
somewhere in the wine cellar and my suitcase should be in it
okay you can get me a card tonight if you make it back manny
the card will be on the table oh nice bobby bonnella day
what's that happy day okay perfect i'm glad we uh searched
around for quite a bit because that was a good find uh and
we know an easy way back to the to the racetrack now it was
worth all of the searching I'd wait oh wait hold on what is
over here oh is this
gross how long was that Raven sitting there what is the tube
noise happening for the groan tube it's bolted down oh just
use it Hey, you lazy bees.
Get off your abdomens and get to work.
Wouldn't that be their thorax?
I don't know.
I'm no biologist.
Give me back.
Wait.
There we go.
Okay, let's see.
I'm no biologist.
You're a biologist.
Beautiful but grown tube intensifies.
Ooh, ow, ow.
Jail cell.
Why is it?
Oh, no, no, no, I don't...
Oh, okay, good.
Thorax is closer to butt.
Yeah.
See, that's what I'm thinking!
Entomologist is the study of insects.
And mintologist is the study of mintos.
This way.
The groan tube sound triggers my gag reflex.
How close was I?
On a scale of...
Queezy...
No, on a scale of...
Uh...
Nothing to...
I'm...
I'm about to hurl.
You feeling a little queasy?
It made me type that comment.
I'm sorry.
Uh, oh, um, wait, sorry, I don't need to come to you.
We're going to this way, this way, this way.
Come on, Manny, I need you to, come on, man.
Manny, we're in a rush here.
We don't have all night.
Please do not leave children unattended.
I'm sorry, monsieur, but...
Here's my pass, young Claude.
Now shut those doors and drive.
We, monsieur.
Yeah, bozo.
Actually, my name is Raoul.
I don't care.
I do not care about your name.
All I care about is the game.
Let's be here.
Wow!
This must be super exclusive.
Nobody's here.
I think I just wanted a circle.
Uh, hold on.
Oh, hello.
Busy as ever, I see.
Hmm.
Oh, hmm.
What's in here?
Oh!
Party of one, manny.
This is how we get into the basement, right?
Or whatever, the wine cellar, sewer.
Not sewer.
The wine cellar.
Remember this taking me forever to figure out?
Looks like the pantry.
Not picking that up.
Open it?
Yeah?
Looks like the pantry.
Not picking that up.
Well, what's in?
Oh.
There's got to be something.
Oh, oh, oh.
What is it?
Looks like cans of some sort of canned meat.
Oh, I really hope this isn't where the old race cats end up.
No!
That'd be crazy.
I don't need any cat meat.
Are you sure?
There's got to be something else in here, though.
Looks like more of that.
cat meat or whatever that is.
Cat meat.
I don't need any cat meat.
Is this like...
Maybe this is blackmail.
Or whatever that is.
We can be like, hey, I've seen that you turn your cats into
meat and serve it to everybody.
Looks like more of that cat meat.
Oh my goodness, stop saying.
Oh, there's a thing here.
A pl- not a plunger.
Looks like a turkey base- Easter.
Yoink.
Looks like more of that cat meat.
Looks like...
Why is he running like that?
Looks like more of that cat meat.
It's the button for the elevator.
Yep.
Bing.
Hmm.
More of that cat meat.
That's where I came from.
So if we go back this way.
Oh, look at the chest on this thing.
Why is it so...
Who needs a giant 24-carat gold cat?
Who needs a cat, period?
This guy, Manny!
Manny, I'm going to become your biggest hater at the moment.
Wait, we went to this guy, yeah.
Oh, my knee, I'm sneaking in.
Just look at your cat.
You know what, I'm getting the feeling Max ain't much of a
dog guy.
know me better than I thought hello hello Maximino why if it
ain't Manny Calavera come to see how the big boys play hey
Manny from what I can tell they play with kitties kitties
roulette tables what's the difference they go round and
round all day and they're both more reliable when they're
fixed am I right Well, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh.
Um.
How's the cat race?
The cat race instead of the rat race.
Tell me about it.
But he's more cowbell.
Nah, he's more cat meat.
What kind of side businesses?
Manny, let's just say our Elmato associates appreciate our
out-of-town perspective.
Mm-hmm.
You got a pretty nice setup here.
You got a good little club yourself, Manny.
Not as nice as my girlfriends, of course.
She's like your girlfriend.
Did you say your girlfriend?
Hey, Manny, don't pretend you don't hear the gossip.
It's not a secret anymore.
Olivia and I are officially...
Olivia!
I like the new blimp.
Yeah, I decided not to let what happened to the Olivia One
get me down.
Wait.
You try to impress your girlfriend airship and what happens
it goes and crashes explodes and burns on your own track and
kills her favorite cat too not the kind of thing that makes
the young girl's hearts go a flutter I'll tell you that
twice your new waiter's got quite an attitude even for a
snooty waiter type hey Manny when you put labels like that
on people it's like you stick people in these little boxes I
never let them out we're all in little back boxes back
called.
We're all in little boxes back home, Max.
Six feet under.
Now you're talking like the town car, man.
He cut it out.
Oops, I'm being creepy.
I'm going to be in a little creepo, creepozoid.
I'm here for Charlie's money.
No, seriously.
He says you have a lot of it.
Oh, I got a lot of it, but none of it's his.
Yeah, I'm leaving town tonight, by the way.
I'm leaving town tonight.
That's great, Manuel.
No one needs a vacation more than you.
Get out of town.
Forget about that Michi, woman.
Well, I'll let you get back to staring out the window.
Just can't get enough of my cats.
Ah, me too.
Ah, I've been thinking maybe I'll get a cat sooner than I...
Initially, I was like, oh gosh, I need a cat.
I'm so lonely.
I need a cat.
Is there anything...
Alright, let's go back to this kitchen area.
Because we gotta go get that briefcase now, right?
Ah!
Gosh, he scared me.
You'd think he'd be more against dogs being made out of
chewable bones and all.
But that's why he has cats then, right?
My goodness gracious.
Uh...
Hey!
I'm trying to get some sleep over here.
Uh, going down?
Going down?
Probably later.
Probably, maybe you could take me down.
Maybe you could take me down now.
Oh yeah, I could take you down.
But I can't eat customers anymore.
Oh, that's what you mean.
This guy's triggering my tripophobia.
Meow.
I would like to apply for the position of Minto's cat.
Okay, Sonic the Hedgehog.
Let's, let's, let's calm down over here now, guys.
Let's beat up that waiter.
Let's beat up that waiter not a bad idea, but he's new give
him a break.
Okay No, I want to go down the elevator.
I want to go down in the elevator.
That's true They wouldn't see me hit you in there, but I
still get in trouble.
I Wouldn't tell I want to tell anybody.
Why can't yeah?
Why can't I why can't you why can't you hit customers
anymore?
Exactly.
It makes no sense Sorry, don't mind me just passing through
to where the elevator doubt it Can't I go down?
Can't I go down to the cellar?
Why not?
It's a wine cellar.
Wine goes down there.
Just open the elevator door.
Then they really see us fighting.
How about a bribe?
Look at me.
What can you give to a guy who has everything?
I don't want to fight.
Well, you name your cat Oslo.
I don't know.
Okay.
99.
I have to find...
It depends on their personality.
Oh.
He's gonna...
Dang it, he's gonna wake up again.
I'm trying...
Okay.
All right, let's...
Oh.
Let's see what we got here.
What is this?
It says revolutionary design leaves can I just safe and
smooth for Kitty?
Do I use this on...
I forgot I had this.
Can I go back in here?
Okay, here we go.
is this on one of the cans for kitty oh there it is okay the
can opener wouldn't work there why not the can opener
wouldn't work is this not a can for just be wait how would
it be muted actually it won't let me oh there it is hmm did
it go off
it wouldn't be muted i didn't touch it yeah it might just be
delayed but thank you for the don't know and thank you i
okay oh there it is oh thank you dorko testing for noise
yeah it's working um but i totally see your very important
message totally not orbital vagabond i see your very
important message that i will say to everybody so that i'm
not the only one suffering since you're missing your cats
it's time to share last week my sister's neutered cat humped
my With his peeing out and all.
I'm so glad that you sent that and also were so concerned
about it not reaching me so that I could read that and also
enjoy that message.
Thank you very, very much.
Very important.
You in chat being like, hmm, why am I in my stream life did
not go through?
Can someone help me on here?
Are we all really excited about that?
I'm sure we are.
Oops, I was pressing the wrong button.
I was trying to save it.
I'm sure we're also...
Keen on hearing that information.
So our current objective is getting into the basement.
One second.
One forgetty beam, please.
Right?
Looks like a turkey baster.
Is there anything I can do with this bad boy?
Stick it up his nose.
I don't really want to do that.
Why not?
Why don't you want to stick it up his nose?
I don't like that sound.
Wait, what about this?
I don't really want to do that.
Why?
wine goes to the wine cellar but this is the only thing we
have i was thinking like we climb up this and hide in the
barrel but i guess that's not good enough of an answer hey
mister what do you know busy as ever i see he knows nothing
okay wait did i oh this is the elevator no no no no dang it
i cast forget the last five minutes with a vague sense that
some thoughts are inside thoughts at each level.
Thank you.
Oh, what's going on
here?
Anything up here?
Oh, wait, what are these?
Race results.
We're saved.
What's the point of coming up here?
Is there anything in here that I miss.
I'll take one, remember, at 6 a.m.
on a random Tuesday, Veeam.
Why would you?
Yeah, everybody, I'm so, I've lost the last five minutes.
I don't know what I'm trying to do anymore.
I think I need a hint.
You could at least act a little apologetic.
Click on the moon.
I already did that!
While we're sharing.
No, we're not!
No, we aren't!
Use the can opener.
Trying to think of where I could use it.
Uh...
It's actually several puzzles you can do right now.
Really?
I haven't seen the entire town!
Wait, are you serious?
I thought I did!
No way.
the can opener but on what oh
wait beloved sanspoof this regal and majestic feline was a
record holder for speed and a favorite of the crowds here in
rubikaba for many years until her career was suddenly and is
this the one that got hit by the blimp week of the racing
season when the airship olivia won on its maiden voyage to
the track mid-race and exploded many bereaved fans testified
later that before the blimp hit sans spoof in the lead oh
that's so sad sans splurf pay attention to this cat story
it's a clue for a clue my goodness gracious i guess we'll
try using the can opener on the cat food i think that's too
obvious of a thing but why not
now it smells like a giant cat litter box and some sort of
gelatinous demon mystery meat product in here it's already
open now do i use the baster
to select i don't really want to do that i was gonna like
suck it up in there or something it's never too obvious huh
do i get them drunk i don't really want to do that No, okay.
Hmm, smells good.
But I'd rather eat my own arm.
I don't need the hernia.
Wet foods for winners.
What am I supposed to do with it then?
This thing is for copying, right?
It's already open.
What if you give the wine to the elevator guy?
He might be excited about it.
You actually said the answer out loud.
Wait, it did?
It's never too obvious.
What if he does want it?
I don't really want to do that.
What is...
I don't think we talked to the lady upstairs, the security
lady, since I got the can opener, though.
So maybe that will cause me to beep, beep, beep, and get
strip searched.
Right?
Or something?
maybe
so is it time for your break yet I told you not till dawn
kind of romantic though don't you think what is is it what's
romantic are you sure I can't just don't touch so is it time
for your break yet I told you oh let me walk through let me
walk through kind of romantic though don't you think Beep,
peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep,
peep, peep, peep.
Sir, if you will, please place all of your belongings on the
security desk.
Wait,
I don't see it there.
You're clean.
Rats, Manny, I almost got to strip search you.
So we have to have metal on us without...
Without...
Putting our pockets on...
Or putting our stuff from our pockets on the table.
You need something that she can't take off of you.
I don't think gold is metal, right?
I don't think that counts.
I'll try drinking it, though.
Sounds tasty.
Well, maybe just a sip.
Gold is a metal?
A metal that would make it beep-beep, though?
I don't think it would beep-beep.
Like, I don't think it's a metal that makes it go beep-beep.
If you will, please place all of your belongings on the
security desk.
That's what I meant!
It's metal.
You sure you're not packing anything else?
It would?
Nothing that would set off that thing.
Then, sir, I'm afraid you'll have to step into the back with
me.
Rules or rules.
And of course, with my dad being in the military, we moved
around a lot.
Mm-hmm.
this one town we moved to when i was in the first grade oh
really she came back here to trauma down the area was figs
acres and acres of fig trees everywhere you looked i myself
never really cared for figs i always like dates more or
prunes don't you just love prunes they have such a great
texture never a big fan of prunes they're all wrinkled up
like my grandma headwigs face oh days poor grandma headwig
she was always forgetting that's an interesting name i
remember one time back when i was six yeah maybe i was seven
no no no no i had to be six because mr rufus no we even get
six seven in the 1998 game mr rufus he was such a sweet mr
rufus we didn't care that he was deaf i'll bet he was as
deaf as they come but he'd still try to bark remember I had
a dog once and it would come out sounding like a cat
coughing up a hairball which our cat often did I remember I
had a hairball once I don't really like long-haired cats do
you Manny they're just so I like short-haired cats they seem
less stuck up they're harder to pick out of the grill what
do that mean I don't know why I guess it's because I'm so
shy I just can't believe that I was shy all the way through
high school I never went to a single dance I was in
detention on the way through high school no don't get me
wrong the boys would ask but i just run away my mom said i
could have been homecoming queen running away that sounds
pretty good right now she always her legs shaking like that
smile is the most important part of any outfit well maybe i
would have smiled more mom if you hadn't drank so much did
you just come back here to ask to borrow my
Now, where was I?
Oh, yeah.
Oh gosh.
So the only industry in town was figs.
Get figs and acres of fig trees everywhere you looked.
I heard this part already.
I myself never really cared for figs.
I always like figs are a personal favorite.
Or prunes.
Don't you just love prunes?
Okay.
I think you were just at the part about your metal detector.
Are you sure you didn't just come back here for this metal
detector?
Actually, I did come back here just for your metal detector.
What is it with you in this thing?
I'm sick of it, Manny.
If this is all you want, you can fight the cats for it.
Why is it all men are after the same thing?
Except you.
The only woman you care about is that Kalamar Dam and she's
split on you.
I don't know what she did to you, but you know what?
I'm done trying to figure it out, pal.
Carla.
Oh.
These lockers have a note on them.
Employees.
I don't care who's doing it.
But please, stop using the contained detonation chamber to
crack open walnuts.
Thank you.
Can I open it?
They're locked.
They're lockers.
So sorry.
Carla.
Carla, darling.
Carla, dearest.
Carla.
You wouldn't happen to have a second middle detective.
Manny, come on.
He does not care at all.
Bye, Carla.
Drop dead.
Manny has one thing on his brain.
Guys only think about one thing and it's metal detectors.
Well, that's the hole I saw Carla's metal detector fall
through.
Oh, no.
Am I going to have to search each poop you don't think it we
got lucky and it fell into the food right wet foods for
winners all men want is metal detectors and it's disgusting
yeah here we go see this is why I don't have a pet nope you
have to check you have to you You have to!
Maybe we use uh...
Our scythe.
Why is that thing beeping?
Oh, I hear it.
Oh.
Hey!
Nice.
Metal detectors beep and then we use our site for it.
Easy peasy.
A little stinky, but it could be worse.
Just a little stinky.
What if we, now I want a metal detector everything.
I don't really want to do that.
Why not?
I do.
When you get a metal detector, you actually want to metal
detect everything.
It's like the law.
You must always be metal detecting.
I'm gonna use it on this guy.
Hey.
Uh, not that.
I can't believe the gold flakes.
I don't even, like, I actually thought that gold would not
go off in a metal detector.
Like, like, I think about like wearing a gold necklace and I
don't think that's ever gone off in a metal detector.
You know?
I don't really want to do that.
It wouldn't.
That's why I thought about it.
That's why!
It is truly video game logic.
I guess so.
Yeah, it's not magnetic, so it's kind of like...
You know?
Yeah, it's strange.
Do you have anything on you?
I don't really want to do that.
If you let Carla Yap all the way through, she starts trauma
dumping and crying, and Manny panics.
No way!
I don't really want to do that.
I thought I did get her all the way through because she
started talking about the figs again.
I don't really want to do that.
Why don't we want to do that?
My Minto withdrawals have been satiated.
Hi!
This game about talking skeletons in the underworld isn't
realistic at all.
Okay.
But at the same time.
At the same time, it's not about realism.
It's about realism.
It's about my real world.
experience.
What am I doing now?
So we got the metal detector.
What did we need it for?
You never check the blue casket club.
Oh, wait.
Oh yeah, because I took the elevator up.
That's right.
That's right, that's right.
We just took the elevator up.
It shot us up and I completely forgot about it.
Yeah, we'll go check that then.
Uh, no, no, no, no, uh, uh, uh, wait.
I'm trying to decide what we'll be faster.
Probably this way.
Uh, hello?
Uh, leave, leave.
No?
Oh, this way, this way.
I think this way, yeah.
And then this way.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There was no other entrances here, right?
That doesn't seem like it.
Wait Okay, never mind that goes back that way.
Okay, sometimes the arrows are a bit confusing, huh?
Blue casket just doesn't have the zing of Calavera cafe, you
know?
Sure, sure buddy.
I don't know blue casket sounds legit This place is a
bopping too
Oh, no, it's a jazz club.
Oh, no, oh no, oh no, they're all look at them They're all
wearing their little jazz hats and stuff.
Hey, look.
Deadbeats.
Hi, what's your name?
Oh, they suck.
Crazy.
What's that?
Labor organization and revolt made easy.
I'll take that.
Hey, can I borrow this book?
Why?
So you can freak out our plans for organizing labor and go
rat us out to your pal, Chief Poggin?
Hey, I'm just looking for something to read on the can, all
right?
What is that?
What is that insult?
Gah.
Looks like it's open mic night.
Alright.
Testing.
Good evening.
I'd like to read a poem.
So what's up with airplane food anyway?
Good evening.
I like to read a poem.
Beauty.
Oh.
I reach out.
Did.
Do you have a pet name for each other?
Does...
Did you have pet names for each other?
Bones, bones.
Bones, bones, bones.
Falling.
Falling!
Why?
In the slaughterhouse of my...
In the slaughterhouse of my soul.
Don't pet the cat.
Don't pet the cat that way.
Oh!
Skibibibbaba.
Glambake Break the mirror Break the mirror with your silence
Bang Can it be yesterday?
Skibby-bapapap Skibby-bapapap Woman?
Rise up!
The lie.
The end.
Is that good?
Woman, rise up!
Then let's fight here, then the sun.
Fighting around.
This.
Oh.
What are you doing here?
No.
This crowd doesn't go much for so much.
in your pictures except maybe of Lenin.
Shh!
Manny, I'm on a stakeout.
I'm gonna prove to Max Amino once and for all that Olivia's
no good story.
Still hung up on Max, eh?
Take my advice, Angel.
Forget about him.
He's a gambling racketeer.
Like you.
Oh, that hurts, baby.
Hey, baby.
Hey, shh.
Here they come.
Oh, they're coming?
Oh, come on, Sugar.
How about a kiss for the road?
Oh, ick.
Don't let me down, Nick.
You're a lawyer.
Hold her head!
I don't, but I know a good tart when I see one.
A good tart.
Oh my!
Hey!
If Maximino sees that, we're going to end up in matching
terracotta pots.
Don't be silly.
He wouldn't hurt me.
He loves me.
Uh-oh.
Manny, at last we're alone.
Tell me, how are the bourgeoisie?
Fine.
How's Max?
Oh, Gramps.
don't start i do gotta get new headphones soon oh i think
she's not okay guys hold on hold on my ears are starting to
hurt i don't remember where i put them though
hey they were on my desk and now they're not oh
it's really hurting actually what
wait where could i put them for real
one second i want to have i have one other place that i
could have put them i think
ears and I actually don't know where they are.
I have another set of over ear that I can put on but that's
what's making my ears hurt is the over ear.
I can't find my my in ear ones.
I'll try the second pair of over the ear ones though.
I'll try and see.
I don't know if you're still using IEMs.
No, not right now.
Arc to set my ears like really killing me right now oh geez
because uh it's because like there's a lot of pressure on my
ears but usually I can wear these for like super long hours
but I think it's because every day I've been recording and
recording so they're on my ears for like half the day you
know and so I have really bad ear fatigue with them right
now but
I wish I could ear ones I'm afraid these ones will still
hurt but I will try it I'll
just like place it behind the ear that hurts currently you
know like kind of offset it a little bit hmm okay actually
I'm also gonna take some pain medicine it hurts that bad I'm
sorry one second one second one second I'm sorry I'm sorry
I need to go get more water anyway.
But...
I'm gonna take some...
It hurts so bad!
Okay, wait a second.
Sorry!
I'll turn up the jazz music, yeah.
The
headphones?
Okay.
Sorry for that very long...
Detour?
Akadoki!
We are with...
What's his names?
Little lady.
Let's see.
What are you doing with a snake like...
Who's Nick?
What are you doing with a snake like Nick?
I'd lay it on, you Manny, but I don't think you'd get it.
Messing around with your boyfriend's lawyer!
Are her boobs made of bones?
Yes.
Snake.
Messing around with your boyfriend's lawyer is pretty
dangerous.
Oh, maybe I was wrong.
Is she good?
Uh-huh.
I'm a little worried about Lola.
That's because she's doomed, Manny.
She fell in love with Maximino.
That's the one mistake I never made.
Oh, yeah, Lola.
Oh, God, is she good?
Oh, I forgot that Maximino was just like...
Oh, your club is almost as cute as my girlfriend.
So she owns this place.
That's right.
open mic night seems like a big hit it always takes those
timid souls a while to get up the nerve timid souls yeah
would it help maybe it would help if you went up there oh i
thought i meant i read poetry in my own club that would be
like this whole place was just a big temple set up to
worship me oh that wouldn't that be like so crazy let's see
Hmm.
Oh, come.
I reach out.
Did you have pet names for each other?
Bones.
Hey, this is...
Hey.
Wait a second.
Don't pet the cat that way.
Skippy.
Bop.
Clambic.
Wait a second.
This is...
Explosion.
Can it be yesterday?
This is a, this is plagiarism!
What?
This is plagiarism!
Yeah!
She stole my poem.
Consider it an homage.
Have Olivia recite one of your poems.
No way!
Woman rise up.
It's all in the delivery.
I kind of felt it when she said it.
Maybe it just needs to be read in a sultry woman voice.
Hey, how about another boom?
We slept.
Life's just some rapid eye movement.
In a warm, cozy bed.
We wake.
The flesh dream is over, Daddy.
Now that we're all crazy dead.
Do I have to...
to remember that.
That was great.
Yeah, but that's the last one.
You think Nick would hurt her?
Only if he finds her and take it from me.
He's not good at finding things.
He's not good, good, good, good.
He's not good, good, good, good, good.
He's not good at finding things.
I'm thinking of buying this place.
Really?
I thought about buying yours for a while.
to buy it for me.
What if we traded clubs?
A little dark in here, don't you think?
Dark and cold, like the hearts of men.
Ugh.
You can have it.
I'm leaving town.
Manny, you sound so exciting all of a sudden.
Why are you leaving town?
I'm chasing a woman I met once and can't forget.
Well, I have a poem I wrote just for you.
Pay attention because it's pretty short.
short here it goes that could
have been that's it would be like almost the same
How about another poem?
Hey, how about another poem?
Ashes to ashes.
Two ashes.
Oh.
Oh, sorry, you don't...
That was great.
to ashes to ashes to ashes to ashes to ashes to ashes I like
her poems I like them okay I called my cat bony till she
said it wouldn't do I said why she said sister cuz that's
what I've been calling you whoa
that was great yeah but that's the last one no no more more
please please Please!
Okay, okay.
Last one, folks.
With bony hands, I hold my partner.
On soulless feet, we cross the floor.
The music stops as if to answer.
An empty knocking at the door.
It seems his skin was sweet as mango.
When last I held him to my breast.
But now, we dance this grim fandango.
And we'll for years before we rest.
Whoa!
That was great!
This time I just don't have any more.
That was sick!
That was so awesome!
Wait, does she actually do any more?
Hey, how about another poem?
I'm bone dry.
Flesh out of poems.
Just begin again at the top.
They get better each time!
Hello, naplings!
I'm slept.
Life's just so we're in a we're in a jazz club right now Hey
kids, thank you for the gift We wake the flesh dream is over
daddy now that we're all crazy What were you streaming
today?
I didn't actually get to check Yeah, but that's the last one
Oh She's okay.
She's fine.
Oh slay the spire.
I hope you had fun I think you guys were all the gifted.
Thank you Well, catch you later, Hip Chick.
Keep practicing that lingo, man.
You'll get it.
This game is so fun.
Can we go in here?
I'm watching the routine.
Just a dab will drop, yeah?
Just a dab will drop.
Hey, man, you didn't see me put the secret ingredient in
these coffin shooters, did you?
Relax.
Olivia stole the recipe from me in the first place.
Yeah.
steals from the rich and gives to me to pour.
I've never tried Slade Aspire.
I wonder if I would...
How I would do at it.
Is the Fandango really grim?
It's pretty grim.
But it's also so funny.
How do I catch everybody up to speed a little bit?
Welcome to Grim Fandango.
It's a point and click game.
from the 90s this is a remaster of it though and um we're
we're we're little Skelly men's in the underworld and we
used to be a Grim Reaper but we turned we found a conspiracy
it's very fun I think you will like it you might like this
game too Nimmy it's very like I don't know it's it's I don't
know it's a point-and-click game so some of the puzzles are
a little you know point-and-click like but I'm sure Naplings
would help you out too.
And then we uncovered a conspiracy at our workplace that we
are trying to work off like our time, you know, so we can go
to the after afterlife.
And we're not getting any good clients.
And so we joined a revolution.
And then right now we're searching for a lady.
like a she was supposed to be a great client and because
that's how we discovered the conspiracy and now we're
searching for her some gotcha funds oh bitch you don't be
queen's new silver outfit thank you good luck with your
rules if you can deal with things like forbidden solitaire
it's stupidly easy and they for you i loved forbidden
solitaire though that was so fun slay the spider has some
elements of forbidden solitaire oh i see maybe i'll try it
sometime but yeah that's kind of where we're at the sink is
full of dirty huka water not the huka water wait wait i have
the turkey baster
i don't know what i'm gonna do with this but
I think I'm gonna take it.
For some reason.
For something.
I don't get the feeling those cleaning supplies are used
much around here.
They look a little dusty, huh?
Nothing in the dishwasher.
Not to sound like a capitalist oppressor.
But I have people who do that for me now.
Ooh, la la.
I'm not gonna drink dirty huka water.
And I can't carry it with my bare hands.
Why do we need the dirty huka water?
Well, I grabbed it, whatever that's worth.
Oh, we had a little cutscene.
See that?
I want to do open mic night again.
Oh, she's dead.
She's down.
It won't let me move, by the way.
Oh, now we can.
Hold on.
I want to save real quick.
I don't know the last time.
We'll just do this one.
Are you okay?
Hello!
Hmm, no effect.
Wait, I'm going back up.
Testing?
I'd like to read another poem.
What?
They're already...
They're already hissing me!
Hold on.
Grotesque.
Protesk.
Fiddledee-dee.
Fiddledee.
I can't bear it.
Bones, bones, bones.
Bones, bones.
Can you hear me say nothing?
Pointlessness.
I am your failure.
The end.
No!
Why do they always hiss me?
No, no!
What, yeah.
So what is up with airplane food anyway?
Is he trying to be funny?
I mean, it's so small.
There's nothing funny about being dead, comrades.
life is pain death is worse my funny bone must have fell off
in the hearse your meters a little anyone out there know
where I can find some tools the only tool in here is you
yeah tool of the government monkey wrench of the man is hip
hissing like snapping except for booing well when you boo me
it's you like it all right All right, who's ready to rock
and roll?
Maybe later than okay.
Hey, can anyone out there help me get into the maritime
union?
Hey, we're into organizing labor.
Not sabotaging labor.
Okay, I'm gonna read another poem.
Hey, hey, quit it.
Give me a chance.
Alone.
Woman.
Eating through your brain.
Don't pet the cat that way.
Oh!
She, she woke up.
Oh yeah.
I'm sick and in so being I am the healthy one the end why
why that was so good that was so good why are we hissing hi
what's your name why are we hissing that was so good they
don't know I'm I'm ahead of my time all right so we are
trying to get into the wine seller to get this suitcase for
the guy that's going to counterfeit us a thing into a union
card we got to get some tools don't forget to save I think I
did just save but I'll save again there's also what's his
name wait a second that passed her out that drink so what if
We give it to the guy.
Where was he actually?
The guy that's getting tattooed so he can't go on the boat.
Right?
The turkey baster.
Wait, where was the...
I'm lost.
Wait, where was that?
Oh,
here we go.
Here we go.
This way.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Sounds like a plan.
Yeah, baby.
So we need to take this guy's spot so we can go on the...
Oh.
Hmm?
Is everything okay?
We're back?
Wait, what happened?
Oh, I think YouTube went down for a second.
No, it's not me.
My OBS says I'm totally fine.
Huh.
The stream was offline.
Yeah, it wasn't me.
OBS says I'm fine.
Oh well, we're here.
Nah, he'd see me do it.
Now he'd see me do it.
He's looking away.
Um, what else can we do?
Say something.
We died and came back like the lady next to the stage.
I paused your stream and it paused everyone.
Oh, what the...
Rookie mistake.
Wait a second.
Maybe it is me.
Wait, maybe it is my YouTube.
Wait, I'm...
I'm lagging now.
What the heck?
I know, I know, I don't want...
Okay, we're back, I guess.
Hmm, that was weird.
Let's see.
Maybe I can give him this.
Do you want a different drink?
I don't really want to do that.
No?
I can hit him over...
This looks like a hammer.
It makes me want to hit him over the head with it.
I don't really want to do that.
There's another screen in this room, is there?
Oh, wait.
Oops.
No, no, no.
My honey, I need you to be a little more fast than that.
You can walk behind the tattoo artist.
Okay.
Oh, there is!
Oh, my goodness.
What is in here?
Here.
That's one old fridge.
What's inside?
I wish I could see.
Looks like a lettuce crisper.
Smells more like a fungus crisper.
Oh, you're so funny, Manny.
You're hilarious.
You are so funny.
Ah!
It's empty.
Hey, shut the door.
You slow down my grinder.
Very painful.
Very painful, eh, Naranja?
Like torture.
Okay.
Interesting.
A lot of stains for a guy with no bodily fluids.
That's so true though.
Actually, that's even worse.
So if I open this.
And then open this.
And then run over here.
And then grab this.
It's okay.
Who is over there?
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, look.
You broke it.
No, it won't shot.
Uh-oh.
Nice.
Oh, can't even hold still.
What are you?
Dead?
Ah, Keifa.
Wake up.
I don't work on drunks.
What kind of sailor are you?
Oh, can't even hold.
Yeah, can't handle his boots.
Can I take his clothes?
Oh.
No, no, no.
Am I here?
Well, he's sobered up.
I send him to Limbo.
Yeah.
make it there by morning.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
That is what I told him.
Let's see what you got on you.
Huh, Sailor?
Are you kidding me?
Seaman and Selmo Naraja in some third class.
I gave him the idea in first place.
Doesn't look like you'll be showing up to work in the
morning.
No.
Tiger can't change his stripes.
I already searched him pretty thoroughly.
Doesn't look like you'll be showing up to work in the
morning.
I already searched him pretty thoroughly.
Hey, listen to me.
You've got to take care of yourself.
Nice.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Moving over here.
Sure,
of course, I understand.
I wonder if Inez has cooled off yet.
Oh, yeah, it happened.
I forgot about my date.
Hey, Velazco!
Manny, do you mind?
Artists that...
Velasco!
Mm-hmm.
What if I, um...
Metal Descendant.
I don't really want to do that.
Why not?
What else do I have?
Get this guy a dang CPAP machine.
Holy.
I guess, is that all that I do then?
Hmm.
Okay.
Well, we took care of that problem.
But I still don't know how to get into the basement.
He stopped just snoring.
Check his polls.
Yeah, he must have died of sleep apnea.
It's alive.
Which if you guys have a bad snoring problem, sleep apnea is
no joke.
Make sure you go get checked.
This goes to the cat.
What else was there?
There's the bees.
But I didn't really get...
Maybe let's go talk to what's his name.
This has been a Minto service announcement.
Yeah!
I want you guys all happy, healthy.
Hmm...
Hey, look at this.
I don't really want to do that.
Oh, okay.
I got a CPAP this year, it's been a great help.
Because it really does help you sleep better.
And, and, if you're not, if you need it, you're not getting
enough oxygen to your brain.
Yeah.
It's locked.
I know, I locked it.
I don't know what to do now.
Is there anything else with the breeze?
Maybe I show them.
Well, no, they don't care about the soldiers, huh?
They didn't know snoring was bad for you.
I thought it was a funny noise you make while sleeping.
I don't think it's all snoring.
I think it's certain snoring, right?
Gotta make egg-fried rice to the stream.
That's awesome!
Yeah!
How could...
Do you think if I, like, showed them this?
They'd be like, look at my tool.
Do you want it?
The can opener wouldn't work there.
Okay.
Or the magnet, maybe?
I don't really want to do that.
No.
There's nothing else here, is there?
Eating leftover KFC to the stream?
Ticking.
I don't know what to do.
Use the can opener on something else.
I'm thinking.
Can I use it on the bodies in the mortuary?
Hmm.
I don't really want to do that.
Shut up, Manny.
Is there any...
Anything in my place?
I don't think so.
That needs to be can opened.
Anything in here?
We only went in here.
The jail cell.
Can I can't open the jail cell?
You missed a room in your own restaurant.
Wait, really?
And you can talk to the group at the jazz bar.
I tried talking to the groups at the jazz bar.
I would say, hi, what's your name?
And they would ignore me.
I also did talk to some of them, though.
I talked about their book.
How did I miss a room in my own place?
The can opener wouldn't work there.
Oh, it's not.
Oh, it's a can opener.
It's not a jail cell opener.
Dang it.
Man, he's office in the cafe.
Okay, I guess we'll...
We'll go back, then.
I have an office?
Where even at?
What the?
Can opener, not a can't opener.
Yeah, but according to Manny, he doesn't even want to do
anything.
Guys suck sometimes.
I definitely did try to interact with the people themselves.
I said, hey, what's your name?
They didn't.
to me looks like lupus been in the sugar again I have a I
have a maybe over here no I don't think there was anything
in here I'll go back upstairs
glottis our sanity saver yeah check out this fancy pass
check out this fancy pass yeah high rollers lounge can you
believe how full of themselves they are over there I don't
think there are places any more VIP than ours do you I don't
know I try to stay away from to that place really why cuz of
my my my problem problem Gladys Gladry oh Oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, wait, I want to
go find my office real quick first, though.
Is it this?
Oh, my gosh.
Ah, to sleep, perchance to have nightmares about spiders and
beavers.
So true.
What is that?
My wartime communications from someone.
He's been sending me messages like this for the last year.
Oh, yeah!
I have word that you arrived in Rubacaba safely.
This is great news, as your service to the LSA may now
continue.
Why beavers?
Because we fought demonic fire beavers in hell.
The hatchlings, which Eva has named Manny and Meche, are
quite healthy and eager to serve our cause.
Yes, the hatchlings!
My next letter will be borne to you across the sky by these
young gossamer wings of truth.
For the revolution, Salvador Limones.
I'm not done reading it yet, but maybe later.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
He named them after me.
Ah, it's so cute.
I would name it Minto and I...
Ah, lady luck.
The number on Gagnon, the says, Rouge, Perremanc, 16, Red.
Wait, what?
What do I do?
Ladies and gentlemen, please place your bets.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm betting is closed.
No more bets, please.
I want to cheat.
Look out below.
Le Numeron Gagnon.
Le Nuff.
Rouge and Perrimanque.
This is an outrage.
I bet on number two.
Why didn't it come up number two?
Rip, rip, rip.
I do not pick the winners.
These things are all controlled by the man upstairs.
Now, please tell the man upstairs.
His chief Bogan was very upset when he left.
And when he returns later this evening, he would prefer to
have better luck.
We, monsieur, don't swear, I will definitely tell him.
Madame, monsieur, fad for sure, see if you play.
Ladies and gentlemen, please press your butt.
Okay, so that's something else.
And then what's out here?
Oh.
That's why!
Oh my gosh.
I haven't been able to check out my...
Oh my god, because I just didn't know that There was a whole
room here.
That's so goofy.
Okay, let's go save Glottis.
Oh, actually, I need...
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
I do want to go back downstairs.
I want to go over here and see if the policeman's left.
Where has he gone to?
He did leave.
Oh, he did leave.
Everything okay down here?
streak we ran out one so did he okay we'll come back to that
guy i don't know if we need to talk to him again right now
go back up back to the club baby mattie what i have a note
for you from lola lola yes now where is it where where where
oh here no wait dang i have a A whole new system for
messages.
Just let me hear.
No, no, wait.
Oh, be quiet.
Here it is.
Oh, you're so silly.
It's empty.
There was something inside.
It felt like a key.
A key?
Yes.
But did somebody come back here and snake the key while I
was sorting the coats?
Who would do that?
They messed up my whole system.
This girl is you.
What do you mean?
That's not me at all.
Lupe.
Evening, Lupe.
Hi, Mary.
Did you find it?
Bogan looked mad when he left?
Yeah, what happened?
Hey, we all run out of luck eventually.
Careful, Manny.
You're gonna get us shut down.
Okay, back to work.
How?
Oh, man.
Am I so annoying?
She needs a system to protect her systems.
She dies.
Let's see.
to the club.
To the VIP room.
That's a way.
This way.
This way, this way, this way, this way, this way, this way.
So someone has a key.
They do.
And we should metal detect them.
But what would the key be for?
If not...
Have we seen anything that's locked?
Besides the door, the gate to the, uh, oh, wrong way.
I don't think she wants to talk to us.
Besides the gate to the ship.
Oh, kitty!
Oh, God.
Glottis!
Oh, this table was for you!
Pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad!
Pretty bad, pretty bad!
Dia, you like gambling so much, Gladys.
Well, the doctors made me promise I wouldn't do it anymore.
Gladys, no!
But they can't get in the high rollers load, Doc Gabby!
Oh my god.
Keep your voice down, man.
You're bothering the other...
You're doing it!
Coming home soon?
I'm visualizing.
You think he has the key for some reason?
Pretty pat, pretty pat, pretty pat, pretty pat, pretty pat,
pretty pat, pretty pat.
Maybe we need to give him some of the...
I don't really want to do that.
Some of the...
The drink.
Make him pass out.
Race results.
Oh my god.
Oh, this guy is now...
Up and about, though.
Let's see what he's doing.
Oh!
Who are you?
Oh, this is the lawyer!
Whatever his pay was for this role, wasn't it?
Maximilio's private lawyer would have his own office.
I do, but they don't serve drinks there.
Got a little lipstick on you, little boy.
Maybe.
I already got rid of that.
Well, I can do the same to you, Calavera.
Oh!
Um, excuse me.
So if I were you, I'd keep my jaw.
I think that's my key!
Everything all legal with the kitties?
Yes, they keep themselves pretty clean.
Goddess in the background.
have to tell this to someone why do you hate cats i don't
trust people that don't like cats because it's like i don't
know they they cats can take a while to warm up to you but
once they do they're so sweet maybe he's allergic maybe
right maybe a cat killed his mom and his grandma
Get up, you stupid cat!
Depends on the cat.
I don't know.
I've had most cats warm up to me.
Cats are finicky.
They just take a little extra love.
Which I like.
I like that they feel loyal to me.
You know?
Like a dog will be like, I love everybody, I love everybody.
But a cat will be like, I tolerate you.
And I...
I'm fine with you being in my presence.
It's so good.
You, I have chosen.
Yeah, yeah.
You just want to send it.
No, it's not like that at all.
No.
Cats are just so nice.
Especially, oh my gosh.
And there's also like this sense of like...
Oh.
when a cat does like kind of choose you like when you're
sitting and you have a cat and then suddenly they sit in
your lap and you're like you know it's like the most
rewarding feeling ever like a dog will just sit in your lap
no matter what but a cat doing it is like it's so good
yeah but not all cats are lap cats sadly this is some dog
slander hey we're about to pick this option and I have to
defend cats I have to defend them a little bit tortoise
shell cats are special I miss my tortoise the funniest
experience is having a hamster do it they could do it too oh
my gosh but I love a rabbit plop i love a good bunny plop
one of my family members doesn't like cats because she
doesn't like how they don't obey her but it's nice when
they're independent and he gained their trust and love yeah
what if you're allergic to cats and it's just so sad it's so
sad i have to tell this to someone i hate cats me too but
they keep the lights on around here I think these guys are
just haters.
They hate everything.
Nick, I need a lawyer.
You get yourself in some kind of trouble, Calavera.
Rumpel Stiltskin.
Someone's claiming my roulette tables are fixed.
I'm starting a class action suit.
Lots of money involved.
We need someone for the dunking booth.
What is the class action?
Wait, what was the thing about Gladys?
I missed that.
What's the difference to you?
They're loading.
a regular lawyer or an excellent lawyer an excellent lawyer
any excellent lawyer or the best excellent lawyer the best
the very best the very best is good enough for me and who
would you say that would be calavera who would you say is
the best lawyer you know in all the land of the dead we're
doing a bunch of bone kiss in here well the best lawyer
would have to be a dad lawyer well the best lawyer would
have to be a dead lawyer well that narrows it down to just
about everybody here in the land of the dead come back when
you know more about what you want no dang it lawyer jokes
not funny you're doing it wait a second no stop stop stop
Wait, what was this?
Oh, my letter.
Uh...
Gosh, I had too many items.
I don't really wanna do that.
I guess we did already see it on him, right?
Okay, so this lawyer, his mother, and a chicken are all in
this lifeboat scene.
Real lawyers love lawyer jokes.
I have a gun, Manuel.
Yeah?
Um...
What do you like in the fourth race?
Well, there's a white-footed tabby in Gate 2 that's looking
strong, but has a slight eye infection.
But you think he's gonna pull out of it and win anyway,
right?
No, that pus-eyed pus is going to lose.
But nobody knows, and I am going to make him mint.
Amir!
What does that mean?
Virago, I really need a lawyer.
What is it this time, Calavera?
I'm trying to adopt glottis Actually, I'm trying to adopt
glottis Manny, that demon is over 2,000 years older than you
Not up here, he ain't He needs guidance I'll ask you again
So will you be needing a regular lawyer Or an excellent
lawyer?
Okay, we gotta go through this again An excellent lawyer Oh,
yes, the best of the best Excellent lawyer The very best is
good enough for me And who would you say that would be,
Calavera?
Who would you say is the best lawyer you know in all the
land of the dead?
You are.
You are, Nick.
That's right.
And that's why Maximino retains me on an exclusive basis.
Oh, why didn't you just say so?
What I don't do.
Odd jobs.
Try to convince Viragel to help you out.
Let's go catch the drama going on with this guy, though.
Wait.
he got rid of the photo right what was her name lola yeah
he's so humble oh yes but what if i really want to adopt
glottis what
if i want to what if i want to really adopt him you know uh
let's see he said he got rid of the lipstick where would
lola be no no if it ain't many calavera Come to see how the
big boys play, eh, Manny?
From what I can tell, they play with kitties.
Kitties, roulette tables, what's the difference?
They go round and round all day, and they're both more
reliable when they're fixed.
Am I right?
I just saw Olivia and Nick kissing.
You gotta cut Glottis.
Look, you gotta cut Glottis off.
He has a problem.
As long as he's got credit, then he's got no problem.
No, that's my money, right?
How did Glottis get credit?
Yeah.
He's part owner of your club, ain't he?
Half owner, actually.
Well, he put the joint up as collateral.
So as long as you're in business, in business he put up the
club as collateral oh goddess well i just saw olivia and
nick kissing manny we all kiss here we're all one big family
you know so are you gonna kiss me or no i mean kissing max
many olivia and i are in love Nick Varago's been my trusted
counsel for years.
You shouldn't even joke around about their character like
that.
It could make me very angry.
Uh-oh.
I'm not joking.
That's enough, Calabara.
I mean it.
Now, let's talk about something we can agree about.
Well, I'll let you get back to staring out the window.
Just can't get enough of my cats.
My cats.
Oh, we need to make sure his cat wins.
Gladys.
Meow!
Baby!
Glottis, we need to talk about this.
Go!
As the half-owner...
Get that mouse!
Coming home soon?
What did you say, little kitty?
Don't talk, kitty cat.
Just run, baby!
Oh my god, he has a problem!
He has a problem!
I'm gonna...
I gotta do it to him.
Sugar pop a light!
Horse in the air!
I'm sorry.
This is gonna hurt me more than it's gonna hurt you.
Demons can't be reaped.
Dang it.
And you live another day, Glottis.
Get up, you stupid cat.
What else can I can open?
Reminds me of someone at the blackjack table.
Is there anything that I can do to this guy?
Wait, what do you mean by that?
Wait, can I do it on him?
I don't really want to do that.
Wait, what if he has something, though?
Hmm, I think it's just picking up my blade.
The metal detector work on the button itself for some
reason?
This area took you a long time to figure out, but it's still
easier than some puzzles.
Sometimes things really just...
I don't really want to do that.
Really just click, you know, and sometimes it's like, ah, I
don't know.
I don't really want to do that.
There's some bits here that you can interact with that can
be easier with.
are there now and
this screen in particular or oh wait oops now that guy
really needs his beauty rest looks
like the pantry yeah I got a hunch the wine comes out here
Oh What are you doing?
Oh, I wanted some wine.
Oh, look at what a mess you have made get out of here.
Hey, what about my?
I tried.
Yeah, it's not safe.
Why can't you just do the just have to wait until I get
around to it?
Can I talk to him now or no?
Almost there Wait a second.
Ah, is there anything I can do?
with the wine wine goes downstairs what if i just drink what
if i fill this with wine
the can opener wouldn't work there i was thinking i could
break the barrel that monster upstairs is running there
ragged oh but monsieur just with trade as a lay there are no
guests allowed in the kitchen i must ask you to leave in a
minute la roy raoul what you doing in there let me go and do
no
wait maybe I can no it's full of waiter it's full of waiter
no oh please don't do that I do not like the tiny places
monsieur no no no no not one little bit no look I have no
time for games of this nature if I don't get these dreams
the custom elves will storm the kitchen looking for their
odours Dang it No
I don't want to mess up my blade I was so close right?
Is it like a timing thing?
I told you to stay out of here.
Sorry.
I wouldn't have to come in here if the service were a little
faster hmm you can do it
just like it man remember oh save the game so true so true
so true it's been a minute since we saved look it looks like
there's a bright shining light coming out of my head that's
me yeah that's me when I get an idea I think he comes back
on his own yeah I think so too you nope can I okay Wait, if
I get the scythe out first.
Oh, sure.
Okay.
Let's see.
See, see.
What the?
Wait, what did I just do?
Okay.
There we go.
Oh!
Yes!
Why was that so...
Hello?
Hello, out there.
Could somebody please open the door?
I seem to have locked myself in this teeny tiny room.
I am actually very close to our phobic.
Oh, no.
Please, please.
Let me out of here immediately.
Get that mouth.
Hey, I'm thirsty.
Where's that waiter?
Your glass is full.
Does it?
Oh no.
Glottis.
Glottis don't do it.
Glottis!
Oh my gosh.
Like a baby.
Like a baby to a teat.
He's like a hamster.
Fruity, but voluminous.
Wait, so did he!
Just drink all of it.
Oh, here I am.
I'm back.
Can I climb this now?
to like nothing can I get inside or
maybe we tell him that it's empty wait hold on shut up shut
up I want to save again real quick
I gotta climb in wake up is he hey I'm trying to get some
sleep over here
Okay.
Okay, nighty night.
How do I get up there, though?
Why is he spitting?
Nah, if I let that waiter out now, he'd have me eight-balled
from the club.
Yeah, but how... Just climb the ladder, man!
Oh, wait.
Oh.
I had to actually climb the ladder.
Who would have thunk?
There's no opening up here.
The can opener!
I let it thunk I needed to actually climb it.
Oh, now get in.
Chew!
Well, somebody's sleeping on the job.
I literally, actually though.
A barrel's just a bigger can.
Exactly!
Ah, it's empty.
Ruben!
Raiu!
Isn't his name Raul?
No one would have suspected to me.
Hey, Vue, eh?
Well, Le Cagg is Le empty, so too sweet, Vuster.
Yes, Monsieur.
Le Cagg is Le empty.
Hey, Joe.
wine i'm going to follow him for ignoring my pleas oh yes
and then i believe i shall quit oh i can never look as a
pantry again no man should ever be locked up in such a small
dark place what the leg cake we're here
which one does this mean yes back when video games the thing
that you could interact with was like out from the scene.
Man, those were the days, huh, guys?
I never want to go near another one of those.
Yeah, the one 3D model.
Just like Scooby-Doo.
Yeah, you would always know where the monster was going to
come out because of that.
Okay, what are we doing, man?
What are we doing?
I bet that thing's really easy to control if you're a big
demon.
I just caught Raul with Professor Utonium, too.
Huh?
Thank you so much for the five gifted.
Thank you.
I could control it easy, no problem.
What am I controlling?
What am I doing exactly?
There's an invisible wall.
Are you certified?
Absolutely.
Why did it speed?
but this is this is where I need to be is it not not here
not
here I'm
not to use the button but it that's what I'm trying to do
and it doesn't let me feel open off open for me if I wait
wait I need this don't know
maybe I don't okay maybe Just checked our records and I
don't think you are forklift certified.
What?
How would you even know?
What if I got forklift certified on stream?
Many of you would all know.
Many of you would all know?
This isn't gonna... No, no.
Wait, can I go back down?
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh my god.
What?
What are we doing?
Why is the game getting all weird all of a sudden?
Watch out for invisible dudes.
You know that?
Octo camouflage?
Took me a while to figure out before.
This one?
Isn't that tricky?
do i need to like get in the the forklift and like be
halfway in the uh the you know
unless unless i have like this part stuff sorry lifting for
forkfuls of skeddy does it kill for your certification i'll
have you know that my skeddy forkfuls are
You can get off in the elevator.
It's just being picky.
Oh, wait, seriously?
Not here.
I'll just keep clicking it, though.
Are you sure?
Not here.
Oh, we made it!
If you guys hadn't told me, I never would have thought that
you could, because of how finicky it was.
I would have just been like, okay, I guess I can't.
Weeks of fun, weeks of fun.
It's too janky.
It's so janky.
So what are we doing here?
We're trying to find the thing.
Why is it so slow all of a sudden?
Hello?
Griffin Jenko.
I can't get through this door.
Oh, I definitely was though.
This puzzle is the main thing I remember about this game.
I can't get through this door.
I thought you were told where it was.
He said that the...
case was at the bottom of was in the wine cell that's about
all he said god oh no no no no not here no no no i'm stuck
again not here no stop turning me stop please
let me off no please let me off not here please not here not
here not here not
here not here let me go talk to you do it oh god is Raul
okay I don't see him how long are these cat races um looks
like more of that cat meat or whatever that is i wish i
could remember exactly what he said about his briefcase
zoomies can last for hours see those little indentations in
the elevator gate
i do okay
i think i understand what you guys are I am but at the same
time please get in oh my god Manny Manny Manny Manny Manny
turn around oh my god I'm afraid of being able to get off
the forklift once I do this though Manny work with us Manny
Yeah, the issue is getting on and off the forklift.
Not here.
I can't get through this door.
I'm not doing this, by the way.
My hands are off the keyboard.
He just spins by himself.
Press enter to get off the forklift.
Oh, wait, that's such a good idea.
Not here.
not here not here not here not here not here not here not
here then where manny if not here then where and if not now
when when i
can't get through this door not here not here not here i
like the delayed not here not here that's really a tree not
here i don't know why it spins not here like it does this
all this whole maneuver not here not here guys i don't even
know if i'm gonna be able to do this not here i'm quite
legitimately wondering if this is possible
gustav's room not here not here not here not here not here
here not here maybe with keyboard i am using keyboard not
here you can you just need to get off the forklift
oh oh this
new poem not here not here was a big hit in the club
not here not here oh my god no stop turning stop stop stop
If not here, maybe there?
What?
I'm just gonna kill you.
Maddie, you're so lucky you're dead already.
Yeah,
it's time for a smoke break, right?
Not here.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for this over time.
Maybe save it, Parks.
That is so...
You're a genius.
Then what we have to do is press the button.
Get back in the thing.
This is all timing, is it not?
Okay, run, run, run, run, get in, get in.
Oh my gosh, it's so fast.
Please, Manny, please.
No!
Not here is the new leave the room.
I got it.
But I can't leave the thing.
He won't get out of it.
Not here.
He won't leave.
He won't get out of it if I'm facing the other way.
If it's any consolation, you have to do it from the bottom.
Okay.
That is, that, that is, that is, you know.
Hold on, hold on.
Let's see if we can try this.
Okay, maybe there's...
Maybe it's like here.
Not here!
Here.
Oh!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it.
Okay.
Okay, let's go, let's go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
Manny, run.
Manny, get in, please!
Manny, go!
Pilot the Ava!
It won't go through!
Oh, wait.
Maybe here.
Maybe here is good.
Yes!
Oh.
I can't squeeze through that crack.
All my saves are this damn elevator.
It's not moving.
It must be stuck.
Do I know?
Do I know how to forklift?
Can you believe it?
Wait, what are you doing now?
He got in and out of it so easily.
Here, here, here!
Okay.
Okay, wait.
Look at...
57?
58?
59?
There's a dark gray lever on the left of the forklift.
This thing?
Okay, okay.
Thank you.
I need the gamer paint on that for sure.
I keep looking at the red seat.
Wait, no, no, no, no!
Okay, there we go.
Maybe I need to get out of it and do it from outside.
Maybe...
Taking the long way.
You go, Manny.
I'm not here.
We made it.
We're free of the...
Yosemite.
It's full of double-end tickets.
This could get a hundred souls on the number nine train.
Something's not right about this.
I get the feeling this suitcase belongs to someone more
important than Chow Chila Charlie.
Chin Chila Charlie.
Are we going to stick this in our...
Oh.
I was going to say, are we going to stick this?
in our pocket too but it's not officially harder than the
actual for eclipse survey all right many give me the case
hey hey i thought we had a bargain no we do but i thought i
bring some muscle along just in case that's not necessary
what's the matter chuck can't afford to hire goons do this
sort of work for you i'm all the goon i need now drop it you
said it boss
got a card yeah all right here welcome to the union many
meetings first tuesday of every month without 37 000 3700
people here watching and helping the elevator might have
taken a long long time while it would have get to pay my
dues okay we got it we got it we got it oh yeah baby So
now...
All we need is...
I believe you earned this Soldier Elevator defeated.
Thank you!
Now the tools, right?
But how do I get tools?
I haven't even seen a thing.
Just...
For tools, you know?
I think I just took the long way, but that's okay.
I think you're definitely forklift certified I handled that
like a pro sometimes we just don't know how to get off of it
but that's not part of the being doesn't you don't need to
know how to get off the forklift to to to work a forklift
probably you think it's in here I
don't really want to do that no
I don't really want to do that okay I got Getting back into
it after not working for so long.
It's such a congratulations.
I hope it's a really awesome job.
I hope you like it a lot.
Let's see.
Let's go down.
I'm going to go see what what his name has to say about
the...
I don't know where to get the tools.
Where to get the tools from.
Thank you, everyone.
Let's see.
Was it this one?
On the card?
Let me see it.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, one of Charlie's rush jobs.
Good thing your new captain's far-sighted.
Still no room for you on board.
I'm just sleeping off a bad one, but he'll be here.
But I'm first on the waiting list.
As it were, yeah.
And don't forget that Gladys has got bring his own tools he
will he doesn't go anywhere without a lot of tools good
there's neither does the limbo don't just sit around here
collecting barnacles right right oh so he still thinks that
what's his name is gonna show a star bird together this time
it's shown pale's bone as I stood there alone and I thought
to myself how the moon that night cast its light on my
heart's true and the reef where her body was strewn together
this time oh wait we're doing it again okay yeah so he
thinks that that guy is still gonna show up so we got to
handle it we got to take that we got to take care of that
guy oh wait where was it this way how
do we handle this guy how do we take care of him permanently
Wait, we can go to Chinchilla Chuck and say, hey, let me
have your gun.
Let me sprout him.
Nothing wrong with the little sprouting of a guy, eh?
If you have his dog tags, doesn't that mean he's gone?
That's what I thought I was good enough, but I guess not.
Some men choose the old-fashioned, the old-fashioned way.
Okay, I'm not gonna, I have to go to the little...
ghosty's room, but I'm not gonna leave you guys with Mr.
Snore, snoring pants over there, so I'll be right back!
I'm back!
Okay.
He do be smoking.
Let's go back in there.
Wink, wank.
She has risen.
Yeah, but I wouldn't exactly called that quality time so
what can we do with this guy besides what happened after
dinner we don't have to strangle him
no i don't have my more dang it i thought what's the worst
puzzle halogen getting the salt or the forklift that's a
tough one I don't really want to do that.
You were gonna cut him out?
Maybe?
Oh, you're kidding me.
Go with some other NPCs.
Oh, I don't believe it.
I don't think that would shed any light on things.
What about kids?
Can't catch you often, but you're my favorite streamer.
Thank you.
Thanks for being with the Ray of Sunshine, Edgred.
Thank you so much for those super chat, I really appreciate
it.
Let's see, who haven't we visited in a while?
The bees, I guess.
We haven't talked to the bees.
We do need the tools and I feel like they're our best, but
you know.
Oh, whoops, my bad.
This way.
It's my birthday, doctor!
Happy birthday!
Happy, happy birthday!
Oh, the coroner, yeah, we haven't talked to him in a while
too.
What's the buzz, boys?
What's the point?
I just can't see how the worker bee will ever get what he's
got coming to him.
You bees got to be strong.
Easy for you to say, Top Sider.
Oh, we can't even talk to them anymore.
Let's see.
What if I show them this?
Calavera.
It is indeed a great day for the revolution.
Say hola to Lil Manny, the first enlisted messenger to serve
the LSA.
Please feed him some breadcrumbs.
and send him back quickly so we may know that our maiden
flight was a success no they don't care oh do you recognize
these i thought they would be like i would be like oh look
see revolution you can also revolution you can wait what if
i give them these this to be like hey you can get your own
free union i'm keeping this little go mine to myself oh okay
just hope you play more retro games always loving though
thank you i love retro games too i love point and click
games even if they're a little stupid sometimes they're
demons the problem is problems of skeletons don't matter
much to them probably i guess so easy for you to say top
cider Sider.
I don't really want to do that.
Let's go talk to the coroner.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
I'm glad I'm finally playing this now though.
Your counterfeit machine is specifically for cow race
betting stops.
Oh, wait.
What if I give it to...
What's his name then?
Glottis.
see into this is the corner's office yeah hey buddy maybe he
wants the the well don't let me bother you because he's
searching for something right what if it's like a bullet or
something maybe he wants the
yeah this what is it called next beach I see I'm finding
watch yeah you try this would a metal detector yeah metal
detector hey just like downtown he said he needed the tools
right yeah you never know what this will turn up engraved
ring a belt buckle with somebody's name on it yeah he oh no
yeah he was looking for identifying who would wear a belt
buckle with the oh hear a beep did you what's he gonna get
anything oh well don't let me bother you always nice to have
visitors but he's not getting anything something with a name
on it yeah yeah that's what he said yeah yeah but but it's
not Nothing's coming up, right?
Wait a second.
I do have something with the name on it.
And if we pronounce him dead...
Ripperoni!
No!
What?
Elasco.
It looks like I've got one of your boys down here in the
morgue.
Look at him.
Not...
Not even a care in the world.
We really are halogen coated.
Sarah can't even take it two days shortly without watching
his back.
Yeah, yeah, I'll come down.
on the morning all day long manny i sought through pure
sadness i find evidence and i piece together stories but
none of my stories end well they all end here and the moral
of every story is the same that's so sad we may have years
we may have hours but sooner or later we push up flowers.
Oh, that's so good.
Yay!
Alrighty, so now we just got to get the tools.
So let's go back down to the kitty cats.
And if we give Glottis this machine, maybe he'll make lots
of money and buy his own tools.
Maybe he will after Aranja turns up fine, maybe.
Maybe.
Save?
You're right.
Thank you.
Yes.
Down here.
Where are the tools, though?
That's another great question.
We can go talk to maybe...
What's her name?
Lola.
Not Lola.
Where?
Actually, where is Lola?
We haven't found her yet.
Yeah,
he put up our thing for collateral.
He needs this.
I'm keeping this little gold mine to myself.
Okay, never mind.
Come on.
There's an area of lighthouse area past the worker bees.
Wait, really?
Actually?
I thought I visited.
everything.
Pass the worker base.
What else would you want to do with the ticket duplicating
thing then?
No?
I think it's another hard-to-see-extra screen.
Oh.
What would I do without you guys?
Thank you.
Goodness.
Oh, I see what you mean.
I see this road.
Goodness, girl.
Oh, I see it!
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my Gosh, that we haven't been here this entire time.
Oh, my goodness.
It's locked.
I hear that groaning tube again.
It's locked, but...
I think the key...
That lighthouse key is what the lawyer has, no?
It's locked.
Hmm.
The music was so ominous there.
This game is in dire need of gamer paint.
A lot of old games are.
That's why the gamer paint exists.
Where was it?
He was...
We gotta go all the way back to where we just came from.
Hmm.
All the way back, where we just came from.
Do you want a slight hint about where your next step would
be?
Sure.
I'll take one.
Slight hint.
I feel like we're so close, but if we're not...
It's hard to say with these types of games sometimes.
Because it's like we just have one more step we need to be
able to get on the boat.
You can get something else done.
the blue casket and not really can we let me go try thank
you so much thank you thank you all righty guys let's go
back downstairs to the chest my poetry is it do i have to
get a really good poet wait if i share them my letter then
maybe they'll actually like me if i'm like hey guys i'm not
who you think i am i'm actually one of you guys yeah
they won't think I'm a poser exactly this group this this so
what did you think of the poem I liked it it was sad and
beautiful like my mother I despised it it was too short said
nothing to me like my father I had no feelings about it it
was aloof and licked itself too much like my cat mr.
Trotsky
anyways oh I just remembered we have our gensetsu meeting in
about 40 minutes so don't let me forget guys Manuel I am
sorry to hear that you have not heard from your matcha you
must be patient and let your heart remain open if it is
meant to be you will someday be reunited huh he still thinks
I'm in love with her here we go hey did I ever tell you guys
that you remind me of my friend Salvador Limones.
Salvador Limones is a fairy tale.
A spook story the man tells the masses as he puts them to
sleep.
Iliad!
Salvador Limones is a very real and a very great, great man.
Yeah?
He also writes a mean letter.
What is this?
I, Salvador Limones, salute you, Manuel Calavera.
Yeah!
A great ally in this noble revolution.
You really know Salvador Limones?
What's he like?
Why didn't you tell us you were a freedom fighter?
Because I forgot.
Where I put the whole scene in Dangerville.
Hey, I've got a split.
So, um...
Viva la revolution.
Oh, man.
Oh, he's so cool.
Hey, did I ever tell you guys that you remind me of my
friend Salvador?
Oh, wait, we already did it.
Okay.
Well, now they like me.
Maybe if I do a sick poem, they won't hiss at me.
Testing?
Testing.
I'd like to read another poem.
You said this to me in your sleep.
Hurting.
Bongo's, bongo's, bongo's.
Ashes to ashes.
Bones, bones, bones.
bones Skippy pop pop skippy pop pop the cracks in my skull
why is he the cracks in my skull grotesque Forgive these
five sins fiddle ditty woman
Skibi-bop-bop-bop.
Cloud make.
Like.
Oh yeah.
Thank you.
The end.
We hear ya!
Yes!
Skibi-bop-bop-bop!
You could catch mine if I dug on this book for a while.
Knock yourself out, brother.
I grabbed it.
I got it.
What do I need this for, though?
Oh
Hello, madame Hey, how about another poem?
Okay, you said this to me in your sleep hurting Wait, isn't
this mine?
This is my poem again Skippy Give me out of here Give me out
of here.
She's a hack.
She's taking my my stick i already got snaps on that one
come on lady hey we stole my bomb hey you can't own words
daddy anyway catch you later hip chick keep practicing that
lingo man keep practicing poem thief wait i want to see
let's see what this book is all about right Made Easy.
Chapter 1.
The workers shall control the means of production.
Wait, it's easy.
It's for the worker...
Better not show that to Gladys.
It's worker bees.
We can easily get them to revolt because they're stupid and
they need easy words.
Yeah!
She never heard a copyright.
It's made easy.
Wait, not yet.
Come over here.
All right.
I've got something for you, boys.
Reading material.
I think these are the words you're looking for.
The workers shall control the means of production.
Yes, that's it.
Yes!
That's what I've been trying to say.
Who will stop the fat cats of industry?
from building these ships with the Boston Tea Party!
I say lay down your tools right now and show the man just
lay down your tools so I can take them yes put your tools on
the ground Yes, no one!
Yes!
That does exist.
Shake your booty, shake your booty!
You know, I always thought bees came in two colors, yellow
and black.
But you look all red to me, my friend.
Ah!
Hey, what are you doing?
We've got the right to assemble peacefully.
Good.
You're going to need a lot of assembly after we take you
apart, comrade.
Ready!
Gotta be a lawyer!
Get me a lawyer!
Hogan, that's gonna make it tough to spring the kid and get
him back out here.
Good thing I know a lawyer who owes me a favor.
Wait, what about the...
What about the tools that were on the ground?
Man!
We do know a lawyer.
Wait.
This way is faster, no?
Eh, there we go.
You're such a loser.
Too bad that lawyer seems expensive.
I think we can afford him if we...
Uh...
Oh, wrong way.
If we win a few rounds if we catch my drift.
Thanks for streaming on my birthday!
Bad Snacks!
Happy birthday!
Hope you're staying cool during this heat wave.
a little toasty in here.
I'm not going to lie.
Push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push, push,
push.
Almost there!
That's me every Tuesday.
All right.
Hello, mister.
Now I'm actually in need of your services.
Virago, I really need a lawyer.
Well, my dance card is full.
So what are you going to do?
Don't force you to do it with this gun.
I could tell Max about you and Olivia, which we tried.
I feel like we need to have the picture of him.
You know?
But I don't know where she is.
I'll ask Max if I can borrow you.
He doesn't like sharing his counsel anymore than he likes
sharing his girlfriend.
you're pretty much done with chapter two oh thank you for
his name cool um i could tell max about you and olivia that
sort of claim could send a man like max into quite a rage
especially if the messenger had no proof yeah we need the
proof we need the people believe what they want to believe
calavera and i want to believe you're a smart man who
doesn't go around spreading dangerous rumors i've got to
talk to max for a moment when i get back i hope you You're
gone, because I'm sick of looking at you.
Oh, this is good.
We can get the key now.
Man, this is going to get me in trouble.
No, who cares?
That's our key.
There's something rattling inside.
Must be in a hidden compartment somewhere, but I don't see a
latch or anything.
Uh...
No kidding!
is just going off like I go kitty oh whoops I did not mean
to go okay I just wanted to leave him for a bit uh let's see
this thing it's always the opposite way that I open it isn't
it or like search the it's Virago cigarette case hidden
compartment trying to think of a way that I could how to
open it.
It just opened up when he... when he opened it.
I think walnuts.
I'm trying to think if I saw anything that we could put in
between stuff, you know.
Your teeth?
A mat... wait, there's no way.
I can't open the part that I think has the key in it.
The forklift?
She may have foregore.
Wait, was there a thing?
It's a very strange way of getting it open, is it now?
There was a note you read about walnuts.
There was?
A note I read about walnuts.
I can't remember it all.
I can't remember at all.
Can I go back there?
Wait, what did they say?
I don't think that would get me the key.
What does it say?
What if I dropped it out from here?
I can't open the part that I think has the key in it.
Oh, yeah, I'm trapped.
These lockers have a note on them.
Employees, I don't care who's doing it, but please stop
using the contained detonation chamber to crack open
walnuts.
I remember this thing.
Yes, I actually thought earlier, I was like, oh, it's so
weird that we can't, like, or rather, I was like, we're
going to have to use this for something.
I don't think that would get me the key.
Manny, please.
It's locked.
Forgiving me yet.
Still in the anger phase.
No!
Hey, hey, official documents.
Don't touch.
A lot of paperwork.
A lot of passengers.
Everybody's back home, but you and me.
Ugh.
Ah, Carla,
forgiving me yet?
Still in the anger phase.
What do I do to get her to forgive me?
What if I just show what you're...
What's that?
New compact for your makeup.
Wait, a little something I bought for you?
If I...
A little something special I bought for you.
Don't try to make nice, Manny.
It's too late.
what it's a new compact for your makeup manny i don't wear i
was gonna say i don't think she wears it and i'm not saying
you need to good what i found i don't know i found it under
your desk unattended there's a shifty guy yeah no there was
a shifty looking oh the bomb it's a bomb oh my god give me
that it's a bomb it's a bomb it's a
bomb another senseless act of terrorism nipped in the blood
by security officer Carla.
Good job, Carla.
It was completely destroyed by our own detonator, so I can't
tell what kind of bomb it was.
But here's something.
Yahoo!
Thank you guys for the walnut hip.
I better bring that to Chief Bogan.
Yeah, you can analyze it with your metal detector.
Gosh, she's so mad.
And stay gone, Manny.
He doesn't even say bye to her.
Jeez.
Let's go.
Alright, come on, come on, come on, Manny.
No time to... We gotta rush.
We gotta rush.
We gotta get going.
We gotta get out of here.
She is still mad.
Well, we didn't even say bye.
That's what I meant.
Not that she didn't say bye.
We're the ones being all rude to her.
I guess, you know, we're leaving town tonight.
Who cares, right?
This way.
To the lighthouse!
This is where what's her name must be, right?
Lola?
It's locked.
Locked.
What was Nick doing with this key?
Putting a...
Girl away, I think.
Putting someone away.
Can I not go inside?
I guess I have to control it with...
Oh, there we go.
Lola?
Careful, Manny.
You may not want to see me like this.
Lola, did Nick do this to you?
You wanted that picture real bad.
But he's never gonna find it, that pink.
I'll get him, Lola.
I'll show Max the picture for you and fix Nick for good.
Just tell me where you hid it.
Oh, Manny, it's all my fault.
Always fallen for the- Okay, Lola.
You gotta tell me where it is.
Come on.
I even had a thing for you once.
hung up on that matcha woman i i figured i didn't have a
chance lola where's the picture tell me manny would i have
had a chance oh my god never mind you just want olivia for
me tell her to improve her taste in men or she'll end up
just like me tell her to get a nice guy manny like you oh
lola
Lola oh there it is
oh Lola hey there's a picture of a tongue on it and it says
number 22 lingua what what the hell does that mean with what
Lola what number 22 lingua hey there's a of a tongue on it
and it says number 22 lingua lingua is tongue in spanish
okay tongue
you got a license to use that tongue we're skellies we don't
have tongues
i'm guessing it's somewhere where there's tongue but where
was it their tongue
Wait a second.
Oh, she...
Oh, oh.
What's her name?
I'm glad this is a fast elevator.
The code system, because she was the one that had the key in
the beginning.
Right?
Lupe, Lupe, Lupe, Lupe.
The code system!
The code system where you give your stuff and you get a card
with a number!
Lupe, Lupe, I need it now.
This is a card for my new code check system.
You do care!
Can I have my code, please?
You bet this is so exciting!
Okay, okay, okay, hold on.
22, 22, 22, 22.
22, 22.
22.
Langua...
Just shoot me.
Lupe, what is it?
This can't be yours.
That's it.
What is it?
What are you doing with a tiny girl jacket?
A tiny girl jacket.
I don't suppose there was a camera back there anywhere.
Uh...no?
She must have hidden that somewhere else.
She kind of sounds like a high-pitch POP.
I'll tell you tomorrow.
What if I wear it?
What am I doing?
Am I checking it?
There's a little slip of paper in one of the pockets.
Oh my goodness.
Yes?
Is that it?
Is that the photo?
All that this paper says is number 36, the rusty anchor.
What is that supposed to mean?
Wait, what?
Another thing!
Hold on.
What does it look like?
Is this it?
All that this paper says is number 36, the rusty anchor.
What is that supposed to mean?
She set up a real goose chase for you!
She did!
The rusty anchor.
Maybe the captain knows.
Yeah, we could go ask him.
20 minutes of meeting.
Thank you.
They'll understand if I'm a little late because I'm in this
game.
Oh, wait.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't even think there is going to be a meeting because I
think they're at Anime Expo.
Wait, where was I going?
downstairs save
check thank you we shall save
rusty anchor rusty anchor rusty anchor is this way where's
this the bees this way
Anchor.
Number, what was it?
Miku?
Hatsune Miku?
All that this paper says is number 36, the Rusty Anchor.
What is that supposed to mean?
Wait, it would be 39 anyway.
I'm an idiot.
It would be 39.
Wait, I went to the wrong place again.
Wait, where's the cat met?
This way.
Sprout it.
What's happening to this town?
Oh, big city crime, Manny.
We're getting more of it every day.
I know you probably hate getting it this way, but Naranja's
job is yours now.
No, Velasco, I don't know if I'm comfortable taking that.
You take his job because there's no one else I can get on
such short notice.
And don't forget that Gladys has got to bring his own tools.
He will.
He doesn't go anywhere without a lot of tools.
Good.
Because neither does the limbo.
Don't just sit around.
you're collecting barnacles right okay do you does this mean
anything to you i don't think that would shed any light on
things oh rusty anchor all that this paper says is number 36
the rusty anchor what is that supposed to mean is it a
bedding thing
Just because he's a captain doesn't mean he knows everything
all about anchors.
He might!
He's our best lead at the moment!
Oh wait, wrong way.
Who's someone we haven't talked to?
in a bit.
Oh, whoops, I'll wait.
Tattoo guy.
That is an option.
I don't think it's anybody in here, honestly.
We can try the tattoo, man.
There's a hidden guy to the left in the bedding area.
Wait, what?
What?
In here?
in the bedding area wait in the VIP lounge there are hidden
NPCs on that screen with the stairs
huh why is everything so hidden in this game
oh my god wait we came here before no I don't
think that would shed any light on things.
Hello?
Oh!
Oh, hi!
Betting stuff, please.
Oh, my God.
I need the betting stuff for the race you're interested in.
Interested in how?
Interested in seeing the photo finish file for, of course.
Oh, I don't have a betting stuff.
Oh, okay.
Bye.
Wait, so maybe I was right.
to do with the bedding oh my god how are you supposed i
don't think that would shed any what
i think i think that's so
nobody there anybody there oh look i told you we don't have
any kitty hats today what you have to wait until tuesday
that's kitty hat day i don't want a kitty hat fine with me
what's your bet then i don't gamble it's a conflict of
interest for me then why Did you call me down here?
For the friendly conversation.
Can you combine the paper with the ticket duplicator?
I can't really combine items in this game, it seems.
Wait, are those the hidden NPCs that I was told about?
I'm so confused.
I'm so confused right now.
Oh, man, I'm so confused.
One second.
I'm having to look something up that Steiner can't do on his
own!
I'm streaming!
By the way!
Sorry.
One second!
One second.
I'm almost done.
Oh yeah, let me ask about the meeting.
to right okay
there we go sorry okay um i'm confused i'm how could i i
don't understand how i i know i went to this area before but
i can't believe i missed that other area okay the second
hardest puzzle in the game is using the betting machine in
your inventory to make betting stuff.
Yeah, but...
Wait, what?
Wait, you just told me the exact answer.
Wait.
You just told me the answer.
That wasn't a hint.
Or it didn't feel like a hint.
Didn't feel like a hint.
I feel like a hint.
Pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad.
Well, the only person that we know with a bet is...
Yeah, let's go!
With a bet.
He's talking to Gladys.
Coming home soon?
What did you say, little kitty?
Don't talk, kitty cat.
Just run, baby!
Run!
Let's see.
Get that mouse!
get up you stupid cat i don't think that would shed any
light on things unfortunately that hint is not relevant
right now oh my god i'm frustrated now i'm frustrated so
glottis is annoying me too much
oh my god they're pinging me and i'm like i keep saying
streaming ah leave me alone
sorry they're like adding a thing right now and they're like
hey hey we need you to look at this thing right now and I'm
like I can't ah so annoyed it's not even just Steiner it's
several people anyway okay sorry I'm getting frustrated I'm
gonna go get water I'm taking a water break
I wish I I'm depriving you.
GLaDUS and his angelic voice of screaming in your ear.
So sorry.
GLaDUS ASMR.
I could do it for you.
Run!
No, hold up.
Run.
This is the ASMR.
Run, kitty kitty.
Run, run, run, run.
Actually, I don't even remember what he says.
Okay, so no meeting.
I am safe.
God.
It's like a small pet, Albert.
All right, let's figure this out then.
We got a little bit more time.
All that this paper says is number 36, the rusty anchor.
What is that supposed to mean?
Number 36, the Rusty Anchor.
Every, yeah, we gotta find every anchor in town.
Yeah, we were gonna talk to the tattoo guy.
Let's go try that.
That's our current only...
Well, not only lead, but, you know, our current potential
theory.
Let's see.
He was...
Oh, wait.
I'm at the right spot.
There we go.
Can't believe we saw Lola die in front of our eyes, though.
I'm pretty sure my first time playing, I ended up trying to
ask every NPC about this paper.
I don't blame you.
Goodness gracious.
I'm glad she was thorough, but I couldn't
Mani, I need you to be a little faster getting in there.
What if it was the orange?
What if it was...
Oh, wait, what if he says it, like, on the phone or
something?
That'd be crazy.
Oh, my gosh, shut up.
I don't think that would shed any light on things.
Oh, gosh.
Mani, I need you to try.
I need you to try.
Let's go talk to someone at the bar, maybe.
Does this mean anything to you?
Go back.
Why?
You were in the right place.
Man, he didn't even try.
What are you talking about?
out
what he didn't even try
what hello
please maybe if I click on his head hang on second this mean
anything to you you mean beside the song the poem and the
bar and the statue by that name sure It is one of my most
famous designs.
Here I show you
Let's see number 30 Harmin said Harmin's get to her.
I can't believe he said it here.
Hey, what is this?
What is it?
Can we actually kill that guy?
Can we- my friend Lola left that here for me.
Oh, oh, yeah, Lola was here sweet girl like daughter to me
I'm sorry.
Papa Toto says hello.
Oh no.
If you didn't tell me, someone else would.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I want to see the photo of them kissing.
That was it, the diagonal Toto voice.
Wait a second, this is not the kissing.
Looks like these cats are almost scruff and scruff.
This is not them kissing!
Number 114.
Marry me, Olivia!
Oh my gosh.
Is 114 the ticket we need to...
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, photo finish shot.
Like, yeah, the shot.
The photo finish.
Mm-hmm.
I don't know what I'm saying anymore.
Uh, wait, I wouldn't...
Wait.
Oh, that's not what I'm gonna do.
Because it does say the six is in the back, but I feel like
this is more important.
No, these look like scores more than anything.
Unless it's like...
Number six is the winner.
right they kind of look like like like what's his name
glottis this
puzzle would give me a crazy headache I'm I feel like I'm
losing brain cells to be honest with it I'm like just George
Costanza Who the hell is George?
Costanza!
Oh, wait.
But let me go ask the betting guy about it, maybe, or
something.
Anybody there?
I told- Oh, whoops, whoops.
Wait.
Does this mean anything to you?
I don't think that would shed any light on things.
Fuck off, man.
shut up god i don't think that would shed any okay never
mind i guess we don't need to show them
check the other hidden mpc i don't know who you're talking
about what other hidden mpc is there i can't find anybody
else uh who else can i show this to
He had to get click closer to the wall.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, why are there even hidden NPCs?
Can you show them by talking?
No, it puts me in a cutscene.
I can't do anything.
Save, you're right.
Can I jump from the ledge and just...
here I'm gonna guys I'm gonna do it I'm gonna sprout myself
I'm gonna sprout myself right now I can't take it anymore
I'm eating a handful of seed I'm gonna do it I'm
meeting the seed and I'm jumping oh yeah blam moment Ouch.
Ouch.
Yeah, how do you think I feel?
How do you think I feel?
Ouch.
Die, Manuel.
Do you need a hint?
I don't want to get to the point where I feel like I want to
be spoon-fed everything, but I'm out of brain cells.
I'm out of brain cells to care!
Try looking at the machine again.
Will it actually let me use it this time?
Will it actually let me use the machine this time?
Do I...
Oh, I still have her shirt.
That's crazy.
Oh, I think I went the wrong way.
Okay, let's see.
Me and this ticket printer, we're gonna make a mint.
We're gonna make a mint.
That's me.
Yeah, but see, now I can't do anything with it.
Now I don't do it.
I can't do anything with it.
I'm keeping this little go-mine to myself.
Use it on yourself.
Oh, my freaking...
What day is it?
Oh, oops.
Oh, it's Monday now.
Oh, no wonder I'm so frustrated.
Mondays, am I right?
Wait, where'd the ticket go?
Where'd the ticket go?
Minto, it's Wednesday.
Oh, here it is.
If I use it, This is the wrong day.
M-m-m-m-m-m.
Hello?
Bedding stub, please.
Here you go.
Hey, this looks different than our usual ticket.
Well, that's because it's from last season.
Oh, yeah.
All right, just a second.
There you are.
How much I win.
It's just a bunch of cats.
Yeah.
But look how fast they're running.
Sorry, sir.
Oh, you took it back?
You don't even let me keep it?
I'm sure you'll be a winner next time.
They don't even let me keep it!
That's so funny.
Wait, this way.
Wait, okay, hold on.
Um...
What's...
Six wouldn't...
They would not have the day of the week up there as like
Saturday, right?
Like, that would be stupid.
Like, six meeting Saturday.
Oh.
I put in 6-6 as the date, but I think that the week is
wrong.
Wait a second.
This was the one that crashed and died or killed the cat.
So wasn't it...
Wait, hold on.
Didn't it say here?
Yeah.
I don't think that would shit any bad on things.
Shut up, man.
Shut up.
Beloved Sanspoof, this regal and majestic feline, was a
record holder for speed and a favorite of the crowds here in
Rubikava for many years until her career was suddenly and
tragically cut short on the second week of the racing season
when the airship Olivia won it was a maiden voyage crashed
onto the track mid-race and exploded many bereaved fans
testified later that before the blimp hit sans spoof was in
the lead
second week of the
second week of the race wait or second what did it say
beloved sanspoof this regal and majestic feline was a record
holder for speed and a favorite of the crowds here in
Rubikava for many years until her career was with me if it's
actually Tuesday that'd be so funny.
But what's the one...
What's... What is the 14...
114...
114 means.
What if it really is a Tuesday?
We could just try every week.
So true.
Wasn't there a note or something about the crash?
I...
I know we heard more information about it, but I cannot
remember.
Time to try every day.
Oh, wait.
Did I just put it away?
My bad.
I was just making sure I didn't have the other one.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, hi.
Bedding stub, please.
Here you go.
All right.
Just a second.
There.
you are cats again ah no is it something to do with the
kitty cat hats i'm sure you'll be open is it something to do
with the kitty cat hats when do you restock your Fuck-ass
kitty cat hats.
I want a kitty cat hat!
Where do you stop him, kitty cat hats?
I told you, we don't give out the kitty hats till Tuesday.
Then why is that kid wearing a kitty cat hat?
Why are they wearing the kitty cat hats?
If it's not a Tuesday!
Tashkaidu.
They pre-ordered it.
Are the...
other numbers correct.
I don't know what the second day of the season means.
I don't know what that means.
I don't have a goddamn calendar.
Lola, I'm glad you fucking died.
You damn bitch.
Just tell me the numbers.
What did the numbers mean?
Ah, brr, brr.
What does the second week of the season mean?
When does the season begin?
oh yes i'm so sorry everybody is so well versed in cat
racing that they all just were everybody in chat is like uh
duh minto everybody knows that that cat racing second week
of the season is is is obviously these days
it's a betting stub for let's see tuesday week Six.
Race.
Six.
Hey, betting stop, please.
Here you go.
Statiums will be happy.
Birthday!
There you are.
Six, seven.
Thanks for the ping.
I'll just stick that in there, but not really.
A bunch of games have the amazing ability.
to make you think you're the protagonist.
A psychopath.
Oh, wait.
Make you think just like they're protagonists.
A psychopath.
Holy hell.
Is this them kissing?
Oh!
It's Lola's last work.
A juicy photo of Nick and Olivia kissing.
They're kissing!
Oh, wait.
This way.
I think that guy was up to something.
Huh?
Doug?
Is Doug dead?
Oh.
Oh, that guy?
Personally, I think he was nuts.
Nuts?
I'll show you nuts.
A room, they locked me in a room, a room full of cats.
The cats!
The room, the cats always run!
The cats are running and everybody makes bets!
And the bets make you go crazy!
And when you're crazy, they put you in a room full of cats!
And the cats are running!
And the people make bets!
And the bets make you crazy!
Yeah, I'm gonna save.
Okay, let's go talk to the lawyer, man.
I'm just gonna whip this out immediately.
You wanna see my little kiss?
Yeah, I got it.
booth looks like naughty kitten and bad time cat are neck
and neck what do you want i want to tell you a sad story of
a young man unjustly imprisoned merely for speaking she was
never the same after the cat races wait what the hell that
he's free wait what just happened i looked away for two
seconds i guess our business is settled wait almost shoot
him oh punch him what was that for the No, that was just for
being you.
I don't have time to get you for Lola, but I'm sure somebody
will.
You didn't have time to save her either, but don't feel too
bad about that, Manny.
I hear saving women really isn't your forte.
Ooh!
But he's just standing there after that sick bird.
Aw, shucks.
You didn't need to go that low.
He's just...
The man was too stunned to speak.
Man, he just starts sprouting all on his own.
Okay, let's go back to the bees.
I guess.
I need a lawyer immediately gets a lawyer.
It's just that easy, you guys.
Just blackmail him every time.
Sprouts of cringe...
Hell no!
We won't work!
Bogan is a big fat jerk!
Someone's a little fast!
Hell no!
We won't work!
Bogan is a big fat jerk!
Why do they go so fast?
Are we bees, or are we flies?
No more lies!
Are we bees or are we flies?
You guys are just going...
C bees!
Free bees!
We're strong!
We fight!
We're killer bees tonight!
All right!
We fight!
We're killer bees tonight!
All right!
Hell no, we won't work!
Bogan is a big fat jerk!
Why are you stop saying it so fast?
You're rushing it.
No more lies!
Are we big or are we flies?
Are we bees or are we flies?
No more lies!
Manny!
Okay, from the top!
Hell no, we won't work!
Bogan is a big fat jerk!
Oh.
Okay, from the top!
We're so scared for a second!
Get me out of here!
Bogan is a big fat jerk!
They're cringing .
We won't work.
Bogart is a big fat jerk!
He's a big fat jerk!
Are we bees or are we flies?
I'll just have the lies come pick him up on our way out of
town.
No more lies!
I don't think anybody's knowing about anything for quite a
while.
Are we bees or are we flies?
Yep.
No more lies!
Okay.
we're good then right what about these tools where are they
they're too big for me to carry glottis will bring them when
we board looks like you're all ready to go manny except one
where's that piano player of yours that's glottis goodbye
party i'll go get him tell him to hurry up the limbo can't
sail without him don't just sit around here collecting
barnacles right i have to go i have to i have to pry him
from the kitty racing don't make me go back to kitty racing
please Where is I don't want to go back to the kitty racing?
The same.
No more, no more lies.
Are we bees or are we flies?
No more beds.
uh oh guys the game is getting a little funky on me if you
haven't if you haven't noticed there we go that's a good cat
all right come on come on coming home soon what did you say
little kitty don't talk kitty cat just run baby what's that
Well...
We gotta do it to him.
What's that?
Glottis, we need to leave!
That's a good cat!
Do it.
I will.
What's that?
I need to cut him off.
Get up, you stupid cat!
Oh!
Get up, you stupid!
Stupid cat!
You're doing it!
That's the sugar papa likes!
I thought he was leaving!
Pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad, pretty bad!
I thought he was getting up to go!
Get up, your stupid cat!
That's a good cat!
Oh my god, we're fully in Grim Fanjanko territory!
You can do it!
Go!
How do I get him to leave?
Oh, for crying!
Wait, hold on.
This guy.
Help me out here, man.
Help me out here.
Get him out of here, please.
Hello, Maximino.
Why, if it ain't, Manny Calavera.
Come to see how the big boys play, eh, Manny?
From what I can tell, they play with kitties.
Kitties, roulette tables.
What's the difference?
They go round and round all day.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Seriously?
Carry him.
I know, right?
He's got collateral because he owns half of your
establishment.
I know!
Go check on my tables.
Oh, gosh.
Do we even have a restaurant anymore?
Is it all gone?
We got nothing left!
We've got nothing left.
Oh, wait.
This way.
Running and running and running.
Give the casino the lupet.
What's her name?
Well, she wanted our casino.
His girlfriend.
We almost gave it to her.
Upsa daisy.
What if I make somebody...
What if I, like, make somebody win and then they take all my
money?
And so we don't have the cafe anymore.
Be dee dee dee.
You don't think you can just sign his half away.
Oh, he's back.
He's back, right?
I knew you couldn't stay mad forever.
Oh, I'm still mad.
But nothing cheers me up like winning.
Oh, dang, he's on a lucky streak for real.
What's your lucky number again?
I knew you couldn't stay.
Oh, I'm still mad.
Everything okay down here?
Like winning.
There seems to have forgiven us.
Please, let his lock continue.
Okay.
what's his what it was two right he's like I always bet on
two I think it was
black too okay was it that awesome if so huge if real
the number number
Let's see.
Ladies and gentlemen, ladies and gentlemen, please place
your bets.
Ladies and gentlemen, waiting is closed.
No more bets, please.
Wait, two is lit up, though.
Do I just go?
Oh, oh.
Wait a second.
14 14 is the winner is it him look at those I think you mean
to am I correct no miss you for oh wait oh yeah to I think
you've made a mistake I'm sorry sir 13 is the winning number
better look next time yeah does it that Calaveras gave
getting too big for his britches.
I don't like raiding businesses and shutting them down.
But someone's got to teach Manuel a lesson in law and order.
Oh my God, wait.
This way back here.
Open those paddy wagons up and start filling them.
And somebody find Calavera.
I want to interrogate him, not personally.
Oh.
Raided.
How long are they gonna close at all?
Cut off the guy, yeah, cut him off, cut him off.
Yeah, yeah.
Throw the drunk out on this big orange butt and bring me
Calavera so we can talk about his debt.
Hey, come on!
You gotta let me back in!
I'm a VIP!
What does that stand for very inebriated pianist?
How many?
I don't want to be a pianist anymore.
I'm a mechanic.
I know.
That's why I got you a new job.
Come on, let's go pick up your tools.
I don't want to be a penis anymore.
Yeah, I don't want you to be one either.
You can do whatever I want to the engine.
Make it faster.
Sure, but you'll be plenty busy just keeping her afloat.
Yippee!
Thanks for the gig.
And for not asking too many questions.
Hell, after what happened to Naranja, I can see why you'd
leave town.
Let's just hope I don't have to go fishing you out of the
drink again.
I'll stay under next time, I promise.
Ha ha ha!
See you later, suckers!
I have no debt if I'm on the run!
I'm changing my name!
We did it!
One year later.
Holy cow.
Glottis, the demon that you are.
Wait, what happened to our other captain?
And why am I captain of the ship?
Wait, why am I a captain of the ship?
What happened?
Captain, Captain Calavera?
Porto Zapato, sailor.
We're here at last.
Beautiful port, didn't she?
What happened?
Yes, sir.
There's some customs officials down below, sir.
They want to search the ship.
Fine, fine.
We've got nothing to hide, eh?
No skeletons in our closet.
Ah, ha, yes, sir.
Look at this young, bright-eyed lad.
Secure about boys like a rock this time.
Manuel.
Oh!
Salvador?
I hope this very urgent message gives to you in time.
Our man in Zapato says Miss Colomar never made it to the
port.
He said she threw herself overboard at the Pearl.
I don't know if you believe that.
Whatever you do, do not land in Porto Zapato.
It's a trap.
Assassins will attempt to board your ship disguised as
customs agents.
Beware, and viva la revolution!
What the
hell?
They're so funny looking.
Little birds.
Viva la revolutions!
Hello, I am a little bird and I am here to deliver a
message.
What did they feed the bird?
Well, guys, that was chapter two of Grim Fandango.
Sorry for losing my cool there.
I mean, I didn't.
We were totally in control of the situation the entire time.
And...
And everything was great.
Everything was totally under control.
And it was totally fine.
And...
This is why I'm never going to Vegas, baby.
Yeah, at no point did anything get off track.
It was totally fine.
Ultimita, everybody!
Stay away from cat bedding.
Stay away from roulette.
Stay away from women that do poetry.
You know, I had a whole thing written up earlier.
I don't think I'll say it.
Not here, not here.
And no, but not here.
How is the not here part the least frustrating part of this
stream?
Thank you for the pink targo.
Thank you.
Not here.
You know what?
It's also gonna be having a stream.
Not here!
On Sumitai!
Take care!
Bye bye.